ONE ON BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE TO ORDER.
AND LET ME JUST GO THROUGH A
BRIEF WAY THE GROUND RULES OF
FOR TODAY- IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WERE
LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THIS SENATE'S MADE. NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
WERE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY IN THE CAPITAL
ARE WITH ME IS SENATOR MEN
SENATOR CONTROL A BOLD. MISTER
FLIGHT THERE'S AN OUTSIDE
CHANCE SHE WILL BE HERE IN TIME
FOR THE HEARING. OF IT NEAR THE
END BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT YET.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY. OUR
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
REMEMBER WHO IT MAY REMIND YOU
TO MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GRATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED AT ANYTIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED OTHER
THAN WHEN I'M CALLING ON YOU AS
A PANELIST THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE. ARE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
WILL ADMIT TO SOME MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE COME PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE HAVE HEARD ALL
SEVEN ITEMS AND DO WHAT IT
WANTS- THE TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT'LL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN ALL
ANNOUNCES NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX OO. NINE
ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX OH NINE.
FOR THE DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO USE THE
TELECONFERENCES STEM REFER TO
THE CENTER OF THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. OF ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED-
WHEN IT GETS TO THE TIME. I
WILL LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT TO
ONE MINUTE SO IF YOU'RE
THINKING OF DOING THAT BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU'LL GET
IT WITH HIM. ONE MINUTE. OUR
AND PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
PATIENT HAS. SOMETIMES IT TAKES
AWHILE FOR PEOPLE TO BE HEARD
AND WE'RE TRYING TO JUST BE
RESPECTFUL IN THE MIDST OF
THIS. A REMOTE PART PART OF THE
HEARING. TODAY'S HEARING OF SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WILL FOCUS
ON SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
TEACHER TRAINING RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION ISSUES COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND FINALLY COVER A
VARIETY OF OTHER EDUCATION
PROPOSALS. THIS HEARING WILL BE
THE SIXTH OF EIGHT IN FEBRUARY
FOR THIS WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
ONE STATE IN THE LAST ONE NEXT
MONDAY. AS A REMINDER THERE
WILL BE LARGELY INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS DESIGNED TO ALLOW FOR
DISCUSSION OF ISSUES. AND TO
TAKE FEEDBACK TO INFORM THE
ACTIONS THAT WILL BE TAKEN
LATER IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS IN APRIL. AND MAY.
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET ME ASK
SENATOR MEN IF YOU HAVE AN
OPENING COME. OKAY HE DOES NOT
SO WE WILL MOVE TO. ISSUE
NUMBER ONE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY UPDATE- WE HAVE
PRESENTING OUR AND I CAN'T TELL
IF THEY'RE PEOPLETHAT ARE
BACKUPS BUT WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SER PATRAS SKINNER.
WE. TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
LAYERED AND MEMBERS OF THE CAN.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY. THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE STATE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY. UNDER POLICY
GUIDANCE FROM THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION PREPARE
AND PUBLISH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD EVERY DECEMBER.
THE PURPOSE OF THE DASHBOARD IS
TO PROVIDE PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS WITH MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION ON SCHOOL AND
DISTRICT PROGRESS SO THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT LEARNING. YOU
CAN FIND ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE DOCK SPORT IN
THE TO HAND OUTS I PROVIDED.
THE DASHBOARD WAS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE
EIGHT STATE PRIORITIES AND
MEASURES BOTH CURRENT STATUS
AND YEAR OVER YEAR CHANGE TO
PROVIDE A MORE HOLISTIC VIEW OF
HOW STUDENTS. HOW SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS ARE SERVING THEIR
STUDENTS. THE DASHBOARD
MEASURES TWELVE INDICATORS THE
FIRST GROUP ARE REFERRED TO AS
STATE INDICATORS AS THEY ARE
CALCULATING CALCULATED USING
DATA SUBMITTED TO C. D. E. BY
EACH ELLIE EIGHT. THEY ARE
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM SUSPENSION
RATE ENGLISH LEARNER PROGRESS
GRADUATION RATE COLLEGE CAREER
READINESS PERFORMANCE ON THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
ASSESSMENT AND PERFORMANCE ON
THE MATHEMATICS ASSESSMENT. THE
SECOND GROUP ARE REFERRED TO AS
LOCAL INDICATORS AS EACH ELLIE
A COLLECTS DATA RELATED TO THE
INDICATOR AND SUBMITS THE DATA
DIRECTLY INTO THE DASHBOARD
INTO THEIR STAKEHOLDERS. THE
LOCAL INDICATORS. MISTER
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS IN WELL
MAINTAINED FACILITIES. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STATE
STANDARDS PARENT AND FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. SCHOOL CLIMATE AND
ACCESS TO A BROAD COURSES STUDY.
ADDITIONALLY COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION COMPLETE TO LOCAL
INDICATORS SPECIFIC TO THEIR
WORK COORDINATION OF SERVICES
FOR EXPELLED STUDENTS AND
COORDINATION OF SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. ALL STATE
INDICATORS ARE DISAGGREGATED BY
ALL THIRTEEN STUDENT GROUPS AS
APPLICABLE TO EACH SCHOOL AND
ELEAZAR POPULATION. THE
DASHBOARD ALSO SERVES AS A
MECHANISM FOR IDENTIFYING WHICH
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL HELP
UNDER THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANT
STRUCTURE. THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN THE DASHBOARD ALSO
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
TO HELP LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES IDENTIFY AREAS OF
SUCCESSES AND CHALLENGE.
FOLLOWING THE DISRUPTION CAUSED
BY THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
LAST SPRING GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAITING STATE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ASSESSMENT. SHORTLY AFTER THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
INVITED STATES TO APPLY FOR A
WAIVER FOR A NUMBER OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FEDERAL ASSESSMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S WAIVER WAS
APPROVED IN LATE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY. THE CANCELLATION OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY SPRING
ASSESSMENTS PLUS THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE END OF
YOUR DATA REPORTED TO CDP THREW
CAL PADS LED TO THE REALIZATION
THAT THE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
WOULD LIKELY BE LIMITED. UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE SB
NINETY EIGHT WAS ENACTED TO
SUSPEND THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD. SB NINETY EIGHT ALSO
PASSED THE IDENTIFICATION OF
ELEAZAR FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF ASSISTANCE
TO ELEAZAR IDENTIFIED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND REQUIRED SEAT TO
PUBLISH ALL COLLECTED DATA THAT
WAS DEEMED VALID AND RELIABLE.
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WILL DISCUSS THE
DEPARTMENT'S WORK DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL
YEAR RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB NINETY
EIGHT AND OTHER SCHOOL AND
DISTRICTS SUPPORTS. WITH THAT I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO I GATHER THEN THAT ANOTHER
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
SPEAK NEXT. YES THANK YOU
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. AS
CHAIR ALEXANDER IN BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION STARTING IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY C. A.
BEGAN PUBLISHING DATA THAT MET
THE VALID AND RELIABLE CRITERIA
THESE DATA INCLUDED GRADUATION
RATES INCLUDING THE FOUR YEAR
AND FIVE YEAR ADJUSTED COHORT
GRADUATION RATE AS WELL AS THE
COMBINED GRADUATION RATE AND
ONE YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS. SUSPENSION
AND EXPULSION RATES HIM ELEVEN
ROMANCE RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION
DATA AND THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
INDICATOR DATA. IN ADDITION TO
THE RELEASE OF THE DATA CITY
HAS UTILIZED ACROSS DIVISION
PART. TO ENSURE TRAININGS ON
THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN INCLUDING
INFORMATION ON THE AVAILABLE
THAT SO ELEAZAR READY TO
UTILIZE THAT DATA AS PART OF
THEIR EL CAP DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. FINALLY THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT HAS TAKEN ON ADDITIONAL
WORK TO HELP SCHOOLS DISTRICTS
AND COUNTIES ADDRESS SOME OF
THE PRESSING NEED THE ANECDOTAL
DATA HAS SURFACED. OUR
GEOGRAPHIC LEAD AGENCIES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER LEADS
ARE WORKING TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE AROUND
THE USE OF LOCAL DATA AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS. WHILE IT IS EARLY TO
NOW THE SCHOOL YEAR WILL THIS
SCHOOL YEAR WILL IMPACT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD. THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE PREPARED TO
PROVIDE ELEAZAR WITH RESOURCES
AVAILABLE ON ALL VALID AND
RELIABLE DATA FROM THE
202-020-2020 ONE SCHOOL YEAR.
THAT CONCLUDES THE REMARKS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION BUT I
WILL NOTE THAT I HAVE WITH ME
RACHEL NAMES WHO IS THE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION
AND MEASUREMENT BRANCHES CD. TO
ADDRESS PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON NOW
WILL MOVE TO MICHELLE VALDIVIA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS SEVENTY
GALA DEPARTMENT- I WILL KEEP MY
CA. FOR THAT- CAL BECAUSE
FRENCH. EXCELLENCE SO RELATED.
TO WHAT IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AS YOU WILL HEAR. FROM
THE CRAB. AND I WILL ALSO FIND
PROVIDE AND GOT PLEDGE. FOR
COUNTY OFFICES ABOUT. TO
PROVIDE TO. ASSISTING AND SO
THE MINISTRY RECOGNIZE US IN.
ROLE AT THE COLOR. PLAYS AS
COLLEAGUE WITH AT OF AT- WITHIN
OUR OF BILITY SYSTEM AND AS A
KEY PARTNER OUR STATE. SYSTEM
SUPPORT. SO IN ORDER TO WITH
THE- WORKLOAD OF CLAPPER. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDE A
TOTAL OF POINT FOUR SEVEN.
MILLION DOLLARS THAT. SEASON A
PROPER NINETY EIGHT WHICH ISN'T
AND- OF. I DIDN'T GET A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND OVER AMOUNT.
IN THE TWENTY BACK TO ACT- I
WILL NOW ON TO WHAT IS IN THE-
SAID TO. COUNTY OF A- AND
PROVIDING TO TODAY'S. TO DOUBLE
THE- TO THE GOVERNOR BUDGET AND
SEVENTY POINT FOUR THREE
MILLION. PER NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IN BOTH. YEAR BY
YEAR. FOR COUNTY OFFICE OF THE-
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL. TO AT
LEAST TO IMPROVE OUT. THIS IS
AN- OF FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND BUDGET. COMPARED WHAT WAS
THE AND I TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT-
AND IT REFLECTS THE FACT THAT
DASHBOARD WAS SPENT IN TWENTY.
AS WE JUST NINE- SO THE NUMBER
OF LEDS IDENTA. FOR DIFFERENT
SYSTEM. WAS HOW KINDS. AT FOUR
TWENTY. AND TWENTY NINE THE
TWENTY. DASH I DON'T. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWO FIVE LEN. THAT
CANNOT- SCHOOL JUST AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT WERE. FOR
TECHNICAL S. AND THAT'S DOWN
FROM THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
THAT WERE ALLOWED. INTO
EIGHTEEN. AS YOU FUNDING FOR
COUNTY. IS PROVIDED THROUGH ITS-
DRIVEN POINT THAT HE INTO. AND
THE SIZE OF SCHOOL DOES. IN
THAT CAN THAT. FOR TICKET
SYSTEM. AND IS BASED ON A THREE
YEAR HOLDING OUT. FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR LEARNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FIRST
I WANT TO THANK EACH OF YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP DURING A
PANDEMIC. HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE
LIST FOR ALL OF US AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP IS APPRECIATED. I
VALUE THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK
BRIEFLY WITH YOU TODAY TO SHARE
STATEWIDE TRENDS AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND LED NEEDS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. MY COLLEAGUES TO
DO XIN DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WILL ALSO SHARE THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORT. WE HAVE PROVIDED AT
THE CCP IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER AGENCIES TO ADDRESS THESE
NEEDS. WE DO NOT HAVE STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT RESULTS FROM THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR I DO BELIEVE
THERE IS VALUE. IN TAKING A
QUICK MOMENT TO LOOK AT THE PRE
KOBE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SCHOOL YEAR RESULTS WATCH BY
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
THE FALL TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS
WILL HELP PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT
AS YOU CONSIDER SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS AS THEY CONTINUE
RETURNED TO SCHOOL FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. OVERALL THE
PERFORMANCE ON THE DASHBOARD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN REFLECTED
PROGRESS IN IMPORTANT AREAS
SUCH AS HIGH SCHOOL RATES
GRADUATION RATES AND TEST
SCORES. CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. OR
SEND IN THE STATE 12% OF
STUDENTS TESTED IN THE STATE
MISSED MORE THAN 10% OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AND THE RANGERS WIDE
WITH FOUR POINT 5% OF ASIAN
STUDENTS CHRONICALLY ABSENT
COMPARED TO TWENTY TWO POINT 5%
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. IT WAS AN
ISSUE FOR MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
PART TO THE PANDEMIC WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT WORK TO DO WHEN WE
BRING STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL
TO ENGAGE THEM. IN WAYS THAT
WILL SUPPORT THEIR INTERESTS
AND NEEDS OF SCHOOLS. OVERALL
ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
STUDENTS MOST FREQUENTLY I DIVE
IDENTIFIED FOR ELIGIBILITY FOR
DIFFERENT SHE'D ASSISTANCE.
COULD STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHICH PRIMARILY AT
OF THE DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED FOR
DIFFERENTIATED SAYS AS A
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN WERE
IDENTIFIED FOR THAT SENT. A
HUNDRED AND ONE FROM FOSTER USE
98% EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND SIXTY TWO FOR SOCIALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. WITH FIFTY SEVEN PER
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND FIFTY
THREE FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. THOSE STATE
INDICATORS AS WELL MOST
STUDENTS ARE MOST ELEAZAR
IDENTIFIED FOR SUSPENSION
GRADUATION AND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. AS WELL AS FOR
ACADEMIC AND ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY INDICATOR STATUS
REGULATION AND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. OVERVIEW THIS
DASHBOARD DATA FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN HOURS SHARE
REFLECTS THE STUDENT GROUPS AND
INDICATORS THAT MANY OF OUR
ALLEY AS HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO NEED ASSISTANCE IN
ADDRESSING. I WAS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF BEING
REPORTED. AS OF GREATEST
CONCERN. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
TWENTY. FOR SCHOOL. OAKLAND YOU
KNOW. SACRAMENTO CITY IN. MOUNT
UNIFIED AND SALINAS UNIFIED
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOW
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE SET IN
MOTION AND YOU REQUIREMENTS
OPPORTUNITY OR INTENTIONAL
TECHNICAL SYSTEM SUPPORT BY OUR
AGENCY THE CCD. WE DETERMINE AS
A SUPPORT TO WHAT WE CALL OUR
SYSTEMIC INSTRUCTIONAL REVIEW%
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF INSTRUCTIONAL
SYSTEM STRATEGIES AND PRACTICES.
IS ALSO PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THE
STUDENT GROUPS IDENTIFIED ON
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
NOT DEMONSTRATING PROGRESS AND
THE DISTRICTS APPLES. ALL FOUR
OF THESE DISTRICTS QUALIFIED
FOR STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND A COMBINATION
OF FOSTER STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND PER OAKLAND
AMOUNT DIABLO AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS- IN THE PANDEMIC CCD
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DISTRICT OUNTY OFFICER AND-
HAVE CONTINUED TO ADVISE AND
ASSIST THESE DISTRICTS AS THEY
DON'T GAUGE THE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTING. DISTANCE LEARNING
CONTINUITY OF LEARNING AND
RESPONDING TO STUDENT GROUP
NEEDS C. C. HAS COMPLETED THE
SYSTEMIC REVIEWS ON SELENA'S
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
SACRAMENTO CITY OAKLAND WITH
THE AIM OF COMPETING MOUNT
DIABLO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
REVIEW IN APRIL. AS WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM PROVIDING DIRECT
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS WITH
DISTRICTS LIKE INGLEWOOD IN THE
LATE HOST CITY UNIFIED AND FROM
OUR PILOT PARTNERSHIP DISTRICTS
INTENSIVE SUPPORT MUST BE
INDIVIDUALIZED TO BUILD
CAPACITY AND COULD WRAP AROUND
SUPPORT. PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE
AND THE COORDINATION SUPPORT
SHOULD BE RESPONSIVE RESPONSIVE
TO PROGRESS MONITORING DATA. IN
ADDITION THE PARTNERSHIP IN
COORDINATION WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT SUCH AS THE
COUNTY OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT
THAT HAS BEEN A CRITICAL FACTOR
TRANSCEND. SUPPORT FOR HIGH
NEED DISTRICTS. BASED ON THE
DIRECTIVE SIR PROVIDE TO JUST
AND THAT'S A RESEARCH ON THE
AND- ON THE IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETY GROW. IT IS CLEAR THAT
THE PANDA HAS IN MANY WAYS
CONTINUE TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARM COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
RESULTING IN INEQUITIES OF
ACCESS TO EDUCATION. I WILL NOW
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO DO XIN TO
SHARE THE EFFORT TO MEET AT THE
C. SEAT BEGINNING ON MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE PANDEMIC
FIRST IT. AND HOW WE CONTINUE
TO ADDRESS THE MANY NEEDS AND
OTHER CURRENT EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY CHINA SCHOOL
OF STUDENTS AT A RETURN TO
SCHOOL HARM PERSON. INSTRUCTION
CONTINUES. THANK YOU CARLA
THANK YOU MEMBERS AFTER YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND FOR GIVING US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT WITH YOU ABOUT OUR
WORK IN THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE FIELD OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PAST YEAR I WAS KINDA
SHARE THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
CC CONSULTED WITH ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO REALLY DETERMINE
THE MOST URGENT SUPPORT FOR
HIGH NEED LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THAT IS OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
RESULTS THE GOAL THERE WAS TO
COLLABORATE ON A RAPID RESPONSE
TO ADDRESS STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS LEARNING PROGRESS. I'M
EXPAND PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
AND TRANSITION TO THE SAFE
RETURN IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
THROUGHOUT TWENTY TWENTY WE
DEVELOP PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
RESOURCES IN COLLABORATION WITH
ELEAZAR AND OUR SYSTEM SUPPORT
PARTNERS ARE GEOGRAPHIC LEADS
ARE STATEWIDE AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THESE KEY
WORDS RESOURCES HERE WHICH
WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED LINKS AND
HANDOUTS THAT YOU'VE RECEIVED.
WE HAVE A CONTINUITY OF
LEARNING PLAYBOOKS WHICH
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING GUIDANCE
AND RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS FOR-
INITIALLY TRANSITION. TO THE AT
TO DISTANCE LEARNING OVER TIME
WE THEN FOCUS ON THE TRANSITION
TO HYBRID AND OR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN A WAY THAT
FOCUSEDON MAINTAINING
ENGAGEMENT. FOCUSING ON SOCIAL
TIONAL LEARNING ENSURING SAFETY
FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF. WE ALSO
FORMER DISTANCE LEARNING
CONSORTIUM PARTNERING WITH FOR
COUNTY OFFICES TO BUILD ONLINE
LESSONS AND TOOLS IN MULTIPLE
SUBJECT AREAS AND GRADE LEVELS.
AND INCLUDED SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND ENGAGEMENT
RESOURCES. AND THEN WORKING
WITHIN THE SYSTEM SUPPORT
TIGHTEN UP MY OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND ACCESS AND INSEMINATION
OF THESE RESOURCES TO THOSE
COUNTY OFFICES. DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE. WE
ALSO THE X. LEARNING SO AND IS
NICK. WHERE WE PARTNER DIRECTLY
WITH THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
SOME OF OUR LOWEST PERFORMING
ALLEY ACE AND THE COUNTY
OFFICES IN PARTNERSHIP TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ACCELERATE
LEARNING FOR STUDENTS. AND THEN
FROM NOT WORK CREATING
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE TOOLS
GUIDES AND PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING RESOURCES AS A RESULT
OF THIS WORK IS SUPPORTED USING
IMPLEMENTATION OF RESOURCES AND
THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM THIS
AFTER ANY SCHOOL OR DISTRICT
TEAM ACROSS THE STATE. AND THEN
FROM THERE WE HAVE A FIELD
GUIDE FOR ACCELERATED LEARNING
EQUITY AND WELL BEING WE TOOK
THE LESSONS LEARNED AND BEST
PRACTICES. L. U. DEVELOP TOOLS
AND RESOURCES FOCUSING ON
MAXIMIZING EQUITY AND
LEVERAGING HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION FOR STUDENTS IN THE
SPACE TO SHARE BACK OUT WIDELY.
ACROSS THE STATE. THESE FREE
ONLINE PROFESSIONAL RESOURCES
AGAIN IN YOUR HANDOUT WERE
ACCESSED BY OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF FROM CAUGHT OVER THREE
THOUSAND COUNTY OFFICES. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE AGAIN
REFERENCING TOOLS BEST
PRACTICES AND LESSONS LEARNED
THAT ARE LOCALLY TO WRAP AND
DEVELOPED AND WILL BE TESTING.
FINALLY BASED ON FEEDBACK
LESSONS LEARNED ITS ONGOING
RESEARCH ON JANUARY TWENTY FIVE
OF THIS YEAR WE LAUNCHED OUR
LEADING FORWARD SERIES- TO THE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
INITIATIVE THAT FOCUSES ON
PROVIDING TANGIBLE TOOLS
TRAINING AND GUIDANCE. AB
ORGANIZED AROUND FIVE KEY
CRITICAL QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS
AROUND DRIVING SOCIO
EMOTIONALLY HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITIES TOOLS AND
SUPPORTS TO THRIVE BOTH SO COS
MOTION ONLY AS WELL AS
ACADEMICALLY. SECOND ROUND
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT HOW DO WE
MEASURE STUDENT NEED IN
PROGRESS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING THE WHOLE CHILD AT
THIS TIME. I'M THIRD AROUND
RESPONSIVE TEACHING AND
LEARNING WHAT DOES INSTRUCTION
NOW NEED TO LOOK LIKE IN THIS
SPACE AND WE'RE CURRENTLY IN IN
ORDER TO ENSURE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EACH AND
EVERY CHILD REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN AND WHERE THEY
ARE NOW. FOR AROUND SYSTEMS
LEADERSHIP HOW DO WE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS LEADERSHIP FROM OUR
VARIED ROLES AS A CLASSROOM
SCHOOL PARENT FAMILY LEADERS
CENTER AT THE TRULY SUPPORT THE
WHOLE CHILD THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. AND THEN FINALLY
AROUND THE DANCING EQUITY HOW
DO WE CONTINUE TO DO THIS WORK
SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES WHILE
MAINTAINING A FOCUS ON
ADVANCING EQUITY FOR STUDENTS
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THIS PERIOD OF
CONTINUED DISTANCE AND HYBRID
LEARNING AS WE REALLY PREPARE
FOR THAT RETURN TO SCHOOLS. AND
SO AS WE THINK ABOUT NEXT STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE CRITICAL NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS WE WOULD
PROVIDE THREE STRONG
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON OUR
RESEARCH OUR BEST PRACTICES AND
THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT WE'VE
GATHERED FROM OUR WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES
TEAMS ACROSS THE STATE.NUMBER
ONE WE'D REALLY LOVE TO
ENCOURAGED STRONGLY SUPPORTING
ELEAZAR I CANNOT COUNTY OFFICES
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTERS WITH RESOURCES THAT
INCLUDE ACCESS TO RESEARCH AND
TRAINING THAT OUR DOCKS A
PHASED. IN APPROACH TO
INDIGENOUS STUDENTS AND TO THAT
WORK PRIOR. STUDENT SO SHE
EMOTIONAL. AS WELL AS SAFE.
NUMBER TWO WE THAT THEY SHOULD
INCLUDES FOR LEN TO FOCUS ON
PEER CONNECTIONS STRENGTHENING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH TEACHERS AND
DEEPLY ENGAGING WITH FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE SPENT
THE LAST YEAR CO TEACHING THEIR
CHILDREN AT HOME. IN THIRD. WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE IN AND
INVESTMENT IN TRAINING THAT
INCLUDES COACHING AND MENTORING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ANCHORED
AROUND STRONG PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING PEDAGOGY TO SUPPORT
THE EXONERATION OF LEARNING FOR
STUDENTS INCLUDING EACH YEAR TO
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS TO ALLOW
THEM. TO ACCESS GRADE LEVEL
CURRICULUM AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS NEEDED TO
REALLY FOCUS ON ACCELERATING
THEIR LEARNING AND TO THE
DEGREE THAT WE CAN LESSEN THAT
FOCUS ON LANDS ON WITH
MEDIATION. SO I CAN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN AND
OBVIOUSLY I'M JOINED HERE BY MY
COLLEAGUE KARLA ESTRADA AS WELL
AS OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TOM
ARE MOVING NOW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
TO EVERYBODY IN THE PANEL- I
THINK WE HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS-
HERE. AND I SORT OF WANT TO
BEGIN. WITH MAYBE A MORE LAY
PERSON'S QUESTION EITHER FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OR
THE COLLABORATIVE. AND IT'S I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WITH
REGARD TO ACCOUNTABILITY. WHAT
IN ITS TOTALITY WAS SUSPENDED
DURING THE PANDEMIC EITHER BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER OR BUDGET
ACTION OR FEDERAL APPROVAL. AND
WHETHER IT JUST AUTOMATICALLY
KICKS BACK IN IN THE NEXT YEAR
UNLESS WE TAKE FURTHER ACTION
AND WHETHER YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
IT SHOULD JUST COME BACK A
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW NOW- AS
WE MOVE INTO NEXT YEAR MAYBE WE
COULD START WITH THE
COLLABORATIVE AND SEE IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS ANY
COMMENT ON. CARLESS DRIVER THE
COLLABORATIVE- SO AS FAR AS-
ACCOUNTABILITY THE SUPPORT HAS
RESULTED FROM THE DASHBOARD
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN DATA AND RESULTS WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DISTRICTS ON
THE SYSTEMIC INSTRUCTIONAL
REVIEWS SO DOING THAT
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT TO SEE
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE- ARE
DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED FOR OUR TYPE OF
SUPPORTER. HIS NEED OF SUPPORT
REALLY IDENTIFIED BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES DURING
THE PANDEMIC THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL FOR THEIR LONG TERM
PLANNING AS WELL AS WHEN THEY
RETURN. TO TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLING SO WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT TYPE OF SUPPORT NO
WORD ON WHEN I'M GETTING FROM
YOUR COMMENT IS THAT. IT WAS
SUSPENDED AND BASED ON THE
PREVIOUS YEAR YOU CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THE IN GENERAL WHAT
WAS SUSPENDED AND WHETHER IT'S
COMING BACK NEXT YEAR AND MAYBE
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ACCESS TO TAKE A STAB. AT OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THAT.
MORNING CHAIRMAN LAND ELLIE
GARNER FOR THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE SUSPENDED INCLUDE THE
FEDERAL AND STATE REQUIREMENTS
AT THE CSI THE TS I
IDENTIFICATION AND THE 95%
WAIVER. A NUMBER OF WAYS I'M
REALLY SORRY TO DO THIS BUT IT
IT'S- THERE'S BOUND TO PEOPLE
THAT DON'T KNOW SOME OF THE
ACRONYMS THAT YOU'RE USING. YOU
KNOW WHAT ABSOLUTELY AND I
THINKTHAT WE WOULD BE BETTER
SERVED ACTUALLY IF I DEFER THEM
TO. MY COLLEAGUE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT RACHEL NAMES WHO
IS- REALLY THE EXPERT IN THIS
SPACE AND SO RACHEL DO YOU MIND
GOING FROM HERE. NO PROBLEM
RACHEL MEANS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HELLO EVERYONE- THAT
THERE THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
THINGS THAT WERE SUSPENDED
UNDER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL STATE
REQUIREMENTS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND IF THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE ARE I'M
REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY OUR LOWEST
5% OF SCHOOLS UNDER TITLE ONE.
WHICH INCLUDES WHAT ELLIE JUST
SHARE THE TSA AND CSI THAT IS
OUR COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR
IMPROVEMENT IDENTIFICATION AS
WELL AS OUR TARGETED SUPPORT
FOR IMPROVEMENT. IDENTIFICATION
BASED ON OUR DASHBOARD
WERE WAIVED AS WELL AS THE
REQUIREMENT BOTH STATE AND
FEDERALLY TO ADMINISTER OUR
ASSESSMENTS- FOR LAST YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY THE REQUIREMENT-
THAT WE WOULD REPORT THE DATA
ON THE DASHBOARD FOR THE
ACADEMIC INDICATORS WAS WAIVED
AS WELL. SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
WAIVED IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING.
ON THAT. FOR THIS YEAR THOSE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE- THOSE WAIVER
REQUESTS HAVE SENSE SUNSET AND
CURRENTLY WE ARE. WE IN FOR AND
EAT EAT S. SIGNAL WHAT
POTENTIALLY MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
FOR THIS NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU
AND- AND I'M SORRY TO ASK
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP THE TO LIVE
PERSON EVERYBODY ALWAYS USES
THE WORD ASSESSMENT. IS THERE
ANYTHING BESIDES STANDARDIZED
TESTING THAT IS AN ASSESSMENT
OR IS THAT A. REFERENCE TO
STANDARDIZED TESTING. A LONG.
WHEN YOU SAID. THE THIS IS
ACTUALLY A GREAT QUESTION SO
THERE ARE STANDARDIZED TESTS
INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
ASSESSMENTS- LAST YEAR WE- WERE
GRANTED THE WAY FOR R. E. L. A.
AND MATH ASSESSMENTS FOR OUR
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENTS B. L.
PACK- SUMMATIVE WAS ALSO
WEIGHED THE L. TECHNICIAN FOR
THIS YEAR WAS AND STILL AM
REQUIRED IN IN PLACE COMMISSARS
EXCELLENT. WHAT TO POWER PACK
STAND FOR. I'M ENGLISH LEARNER
PROFESSION GROUP PROFICIENCY
PROCESS THANK YOU. A. M. THEN
ARM. IT THE OTHER THING THAT I
WAS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IT AND
WHAT YOU SAID IS THIS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE TO
GRANT A WAIVER FOR THE STATE TO
SUSPEND ASSESSMENTS OR IS IT
JUST THE STATE DOES ASSESSMENTS
AS PER STATE LAW THEY CAN
SUSPENDED ON THE STATE LEVEL
BUT THEY DON'T GET TO REALLY
SUSPENDED UNTIL THE FEDS GRANT
A WAIVER IS THAT CORRECT THAT
IS CORRECT IT REQUIRES BOTH
OKAY. SODA IF THE GOVERNOR DID
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH SHE
DID IT JUST DOESN'T REALLY TAKE
AFFECT UNTIL THE OF THE FEDS
GRANT THE WAIVER ON TOP OF IT
THAT IS CORRECT AND HOW LONG
HAS IT TAKEN THE FEDS TO DO
AWAY FOR IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IT DEPENDS ON THE
TYPE OF WAIVER THE AND BITES-
THE LAST WAIVER THAT THEY
ISSUED WAS STREAMLINED WAIVER
WHICH AT THEIR INVITATION.
BASED SIGNALED THROUGH STATES
THAT IF WE SUBMITTED THIS
WAIVER IT WOULD BE GRANTED
ONLY. IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
THEN WE WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A GENERAL WAIVER
PROCESS AND THAT PROCESS COULD
TAKE MONTHS. AND THEN IT'S
EXPECTED THAT FOR THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR. EVERYTHING WILL
COME BACK IT SUGGESTED WE WILL
ALL MAKE AN ASSESSMENT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
WHETHER THERE'S SOMETHING FROM
THE PANDEMIC THAT STILL IN
EFFECT WOULD CAUSE. A REASON
NOT TO COME BACK FULLY IN THE
ASSESSMENTS IN THE DASHBOARD IS
THAT RIGHT. THAT IS CORRECT FOR
THIS NEXT YEAR BUT THAT'S ALSO
CORRECT READ THIS YEAR AS WELL
SO I AT THIS TIME WE ARE
CURRENTLY PENDINE- ANY WAIVER
FROM THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH ASSESSMENTS. NO I'M NOT
INTERESTED IN THIS YOU MEAN FOR
THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR WERE
IN. YES THAT WAS GREAT HOW CAN
A AND IS THAT BASED ASSESSMENTS
AFTER DISTANCE LEARNING IS THAT
BASICALLY WIDE ASSESSMENTS ARE
CONTINUING. AND GOING TO DO IT.
I'M SORRY. THE SCHOOLS OF
OVERWHELMINGLY BEEN AND
DISTANCE LEARNING SO IT'S
REALLY AN ASSESSMENT IN GENERAL
OF DISTANCE LEARNING OF THE
SUCCESS OR THE PROGRESS MADE AS
A RESULT OR NOT MADE AS A
RESULT OF DISTANCE LEARNING.
YES IT WOULD IT WOULD BE A
SIMILAR TALL ASSESSMENTS
ACTUALLY I WOULD SAY WITH THE
SUMMIT IF IS THAT IT WOULD BE
AN ASSESSMENT OF TEACHING AND
LEARNING AND FOR THIS YEAR WITH
IN THE CONTEXT OF KOPEN. AND
WILL THERE BE SOME SPECIAL
VALUE TO THAT BECAUSE- THERE
CAN BE A TRUE ASSESSMENT OF.
DISTANCE LEARNING AND IF. IT
GOT FOR BID BUT BUT IF I WAS
EVER A TIME WE HAD TO DO
DISTANCE LEARNING AGAIN. THE
ASSESSMENT WOULD GIVE US A READ
ON HOW TO WEAR THE DEFICIENCIES
WERE IN DISTANCE LEARNING. WE
WOULD HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTAND
OF THAT UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
OF ONCE WE COLLECT THE DATA TAT
TO SEE THIS THE WHAT THE
VALIDITY AND RELIABILITY OF THE
DATA WOULD BE BUT THAT IS OUR
WHOLE. THANK YOU. AND THEN LET
ME ASK THE COLLABORATIVE A
QUESTION BECAUSE- AND I DIDN'T
KEEP A LIST OF THE SCHOOLS YOU
TALKED ABOUT TWO SCHOOLS THAT
YOU DID TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO ONE FOR WYO I REMEMBER THAT
BECAUSE I'M- PROBABLY THE ONLY
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT'S PRODUCT OF THE HIGHER
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND THEN
YOU SAID FOR THAT YOU'RE DOING
AND R. ONE WAS SALINAS. WHAT
DID YOU LEARN FROM THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE YOU
OFFERED TO THOSE FIRST TWO.
THAT WILL HELP YOU WITH THE
NEXT FOR THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE KNOWN. WHEN YOU STARTED
OUT DOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SHIN SO WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
FROM WORKING WITH INGLEWOOD
UNIFIED AS WELL AS VALLEJO CITY
UNIFIED- PRIMARILY WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
EFFORT THAT NEEDS TO BE
PROVIDE- THAT ME SO CURRENT.
AND BUILDING CAPACITY- ON
EITHER HE INSTRUCTIONAL SYSTEMS
AND STRUCTURES THAT MAYBE
THEY'VE BEEN MISSING SO THINGS
LIKE WHAT ARE YOUR
INSTRUCTIONAL PRIORITIES WHAT
ARE YOUR BENCHMARKS AND TARGETS
AND HOW DO WE START TO REALLY
ENGAGE IN CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT CYCLES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE MAKING THE
PROPER HE CAME TO- ACHIEVE. THE
OTHER THING WE HAVE FOUND IS
THAT PROFESSIONAL LEARNING OR
KINDS OF SUPPORTS FOR TEACHERS
REALLY SHOULD BE GROUNDED ON A
FEW PARTIES TOO OFTEN MANY OF
OUR DISTRICTS ARE TRYING TO
TAKE ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS. AND WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS SOME ISSUES OF
EQUITY A REALLY REQUIRES YOU TO
LOOK AT THE OVERALL
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY BUT THEN
TRY TO SEE WHAT NEEDS TO BE
UNIQUE FOR CERTAIN STUDENT
GROUPS. AND SO BUILDING THEIR
CAPACITY WORKING WITH THEIR
TEACHERS TO BE ABLE TO- LEARN
WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST
PRACTICES TO BENEFIT THOSE
STUDENTS PRIMARILY. WE'VE ALSO
FOUND THAT SOME PROCEDURES FOR
EXAMPLE ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
FIND THAT. WE MAY NEED TO
ESTABLISH STRONGER PROCEDURES
THAT OCCUR ALL YEAR LONG RATHER
THAN AT THE TIME OF
REGISTRATION OR THINGS LIKE
THAT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
STUDENTS WHO NEED THOSE
SUPPORTS THE MOST. OF THEM
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR RATHER THAN
AT CERTAIN PERIODS OF TIME IN
THE YEAR- AND THEN I WOULD SAY
LASTLY THE OTHER THING WE HAVE
FOUND IS THAT WE NEED TO ALSO
INVEST IN SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT EITHER ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE COUNTY
OFFICE- A THROUGH C. D. THROUGH
CCTV TO ENSURE THAT THOSE-
TARGETED. AREAS WHERE WE'RE
SEEING THE MOST INTENSIVE
INTERVENTION IS NEEDED THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE THAT KIND OF DAY TO
DAY SUPPORT IN PRACTICE OF
ORGANISED. THE ACCELERATION OF
IMPROVEMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYBODY ELSE WISH TO. ON
THAT BEFORE WE MOVE ON. THEN
LET ME. ASK SENATOR MEN SENATOR
MAN HAS NO QUESTIONS. SOLET ME
THANK THIS PANEL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE TO
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS AND TRAILER
BILL PROPOSALS WE HAVE DOCTOR
MERRY SANDY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. AND KIM LEAHY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LET'S BEGIN WITH DOCTOR CINDY.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH A GOOD MORNING
SENATOR THERE'D MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS MERRY
SIXTY SANTEE ALLEY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. AS
INDICATED ON YOUR AGENDA IN
YOUR AGENDA MATERIALS THE
COMMISSION HIS CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT STANDARDS FOR. THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CREDENTIALING
THE EDUCATION WORKFORCE
ACCREDITING APPROVED SPONSORS
OF EDUCATOR PREPARATION AND
ENFORCING STANDARDS OF PRACTICE
AND CONDUCT FOR CREDENTIALED
EDUCATORS. IN ADDITION THE
COMMISSION ESTABLISHES AND
MAINTAINS EXAMINATIONS AND
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS FOR
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTERS
FEATURE. RECRUITMENT GRANTS.
SHINN'S OPERATING BUDGET IS
SUPPORTED BY CREDENTIAL AND
EXAMINATION FEES I'M PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT WE ARE IN
REASONABLY GOOD SHAPE ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED THIS YEAR. OR
YEAR TO DATE REVENUES ARE DOWN
BUT OUR RESERVES ARE SUFFICIENT
TO CARRY US THROUGH AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THOSE DETAILS. DURING THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR WE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER
CREDENTIAL APPLICATIONS THAN
USUAL MOSTLY FROM THE RANKS OF
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS AS YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN CLASSROOMS TO SUBSTITUTE
TEACH IN. AND THAT POPULATION
HAS SLOWED DOWN IN OUR
CREDENTIAL APPLICATION POOL. WE
ATTRIBUTE THIS TO SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND EXPECT THAT OUR
SCHOOLS REOPEN THIS SPRING WILL
BEGIN TO SEE AN INCREASE IN
THIS CATEGORY OF CREDENTIALS.
SO THIS TIME LAST YEAR. THE
COMMISSION WAS PLANNING FOR
SIGNIFICANT INFUSION OF FUNDING
TO SUPPORT TEACHER RESIDENCIES
AND OTHER RECRUITMENT PROGRAMS.
TO WORK TOWARD ELIMINATING
TEACHER SHORTAGES. WE HAD
RECEIVED FUNDING OR TO THE
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
RENEWAL TO LAUNCH SIGNIFICANT
NEW WORK IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. DEPENDING ARE WORK
WITH PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS AND ENGAGING IN
DEEP CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FIELD ABOUT OUR CURRENT TEACHER
EXAMINATIONS PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREA OF READING. ON MARCH
NINETEENTH OF COURSE WE HAD A
HARD STOP. SCHOOLS AND
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION CLOSED THEIR
BUILDINGS AND MOVED QUICKLY TO
IMPLEMENT ONLINE INSTRUCTION
AND FINISH OUT THE SCHOOL YEAR.
OUR EMPLOYEES TRANSITION TO
TELEWORK AND LIKE EVERY OTHER
ENTERPRISES WE WERE FACED WITH
THE QUESTION WHAT DO WE DO NOW.
PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE WE WERE FACED WITH WAS
THE IMPACT OF SCHOOL CLOSURES
AND THE MOVE TO ONLINE LEARNING
IN CLINICAL PRACTICE FOR
TEACHERS IN TRAINING. ALL AND
THE CLOSURE OF- TESTING CENTERS
FOR TEACHERS WAS ALSO A
CRITICAL CRITICAL IMPACT. THE
PIPELINE INTO TEACHING WAS
ESSENTIALLY SHUT DOWN IN THE
SPRING OF THIS YEAR BRIEFLY.
TEACHERS WHO NEEDED TO COMPLETE
THEIR STUDENT TEACHING AND PASS
TESTS AND PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS TO EARN THEIR
CREDENTIALS WOULD NOT DO SO
BECAUSE TESTING CENTERS WERE
CLOSED. NEITHER COULD
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS WHO ARE
SEEKING TO ENROLL IN TEACHER
PREPARATION COMPLETE THEIR
BASIC SKILLS OR SUBJECT MATTER
TESTING IN ORDER TO GET IN. SO
IN EARLY JUNE THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
POSTPONING THE DATES BY WHICH
TEACHERS COULD NOT MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO ENTER
PREPARATION. COMPLETE THEIR
BASIC SKILLS AND SUBJECT MATTER
MATTER REQUIREMENTS PRIOR TO
EARNING THEIR CREDENTIALS AND
ALLOWING TEACHERS IN TRAINING
TO EARN THEIR CREDENTIALS AND
BEGIN TEACHING LAST FALL. THEY
WERE ALLOWED THROUGH THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO COMPLETE
THEIR PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS
IN THE READING INSTRUCTIONAL
COMPETENCE TEST FOR THOSE WHO
NEEDED IT. DURING THEIR FIRST
YEARS OF TEACHING. LAST YEAR'S
TRAILER BILL EXTENDED THESE
ALLOWANCES FOR ANOTHER YEAR
AGAIN PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT AND
IMPORTANT SUPPORT TO KEEP OUR
PIPELINE INTO TEACHING. MOVING
FORWARD. IN ADDITION THE
COMMISSION ENGAGED WITH THE
PREPARATION COMMUNITY WHO
IDENTIFY OTHER PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS THE COULD BE
SUSPENDED MOVED OR ADJUSTED. AT
ITS FOR A CREDENTIAL WHO WERE
UNABLE TO COMPLETE ALL
REQUIREMENTS LAST YEAR DUE TO
CODE RELATED SCHOOL CLOSURES.
WERE ELIGIBLE TO BEGIN TEACHING
ON WAIVERS AND TO COMPLETE
THOSE PROGRAMS WITHIN ONE YEAR.
WE ARE FORTUNATE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE HAVE AN INDUCTION
PROGRAM FOR NEW TEACHERS- THAT
DIDN'T PICK THEM UP WHEN THEY
COMPLETE PREPARATION AND HELPS
THEM TO GET GROUNDED IN
TEACHING. YOUR INTENSIVE
SUPPORT AND MENTORING WHILE
THEY ON BOARD. MISSION STAFF
HAVE BEEN WORKING INTENSIVELY
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES OF
PREPARATION AND INDUCTION THE
SMOOTH THE TRANSITION FOR
TEACHERS WHO'VE EXPERIENCED
THESE INTERRUPTIONS WHERE
PREPARATION PATHWAYS. WERE
ENCOURAGED BY THE COMMITMENT OF
EDUCATORS ACROSS THE CONTINUUM
TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT NEEDED
TO SUSTAIN NEW TEACHERS COMING
THROUGH THIS YEAR. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS IN
THIS BUDGET WHERE SITE LOOKING
INTO THE TESTING ISSUES THAT
THAT STOPPED US THIS YEAR.
COURT FOR THE BASIC SKILLS
TESTS WOULD BE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THAT
WOULD CREATE YET- ADDITIONAL
ALTERNATIVE WAY IN WHICH
CANDIDATES TO MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT. THEY'RE ALREADY
EXIST OTHER ROUTE OTHER-
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET THE BASIC
SKILLS REQUIREMENTS BUT WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
HERE IS TO RECOGNIZE HIGH LEVEL
PERFORMANCE IN UNDERGRADUATE
COURSEWORK AS MEETING. THE
REQUIREMENT FOR BASIC SKILLS IN
READING WRITING AND MATHEMATICS.
WE BELIEVE THIS WILL EASE UP. I
WORK OPPORTUNITIES AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TEACHERS TO
MOVE INTO TEACHER PREPARATION
WHICH IS REALLY WHERE WE WANT
THEM IN ORDER TO GET THEM INTO
THE PROFESSION. SIMILARLY WITH
THE SUBJECT MATTER EXAMINATION
THE CALIFORNIA SUBJECT EXAMINEE
TEACHERS WERE C. SAID. WELL WE
ARE ALREADY HEALTH OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY ENACTED.
PLEASE CALL MULTIPLE PATHWAYS
MEET THIS REQUIREMENT EITHER
THROUGH TO. AND IT'S A IT'S
LIKE A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE IN
A SUBJECT AREA THEY
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WITH
THIS TEST I USED TO LOOK AT IN
A WAY TO COMBINE THESE
APPROACHES WERE CANDIDATES WHO
MIGHT TAKE THE TEST ONCE- AND
MAYBE PASSED TWO OF THE
SUBTESTS BILL THE THIRD TEST
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPLETE COURSEWORK THAT IS
EQUIVALENT TO THAT WERE AND AN
EQUALLY RIGOROUS TO DEMONSTRATE
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCE. ALSO
THAT OPPORTUNITY WE ALSO SEE AS
A WAY OF INCREASING PATHWAYS
INTO TEACHER PREPARATION WHERE
THE REAL WORK OF PUTTING IT ALL
TOGETHER BEGINS ON THE CLOSURE
OF TESTING CENTERS THIS YEAR-
SHED A HARSH LIGHT ON WHAT WE
WERE SUBJECT TO BEEN HELD UP
BY. WE NEED IN THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A PIPELINE OF
TEACHERS MOVING FORWARD HAVING
TESTING CENTERS CLOSE AND STOP
THAT PIPELINE IS REALLY NOT A
GOOD POLICY STANCE WE'RE GOOD
PROGRAMMATIC STANDS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THESE
PROPOSALS WE BELIEVE WILL ADD
NOT JUST AS A SOLUTION TO AN
EMERGENCY SHORT TERM PROBLEM.
BUT CREATE LEGITIMATE AND
IMPORTANT ALTERNATIVES FOR
TEACHERS TO MEET THEIR ENTRY
LEVEL REQUIREMENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN BENEFIT FROM PREPARATION
AND MOVING TO TEACHING FINALLY
THE FUNDING THAT IS SET ASIDE
FOR UPDATING TEST WILL BE
AVAILABLE THEN FOR THE
COMMISSION TO TAKE A LOOK AT
ITS READING INSTRUCTIONAL
COMPETENCE ASSESSMENT. WHICH
HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF SESSIONS ARE AND TO BEGIN TO
SERIOUSLY UPDATED WE HAVE NOT
UPDATED THAT TEST FOR A WHILE
AND IT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
AGAIN IN TERMS OF EMERGING
SCIENCE OF READING. THE NEW
FRAMEWORKS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED ABOUT TESTING OVERALL
WE HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THAT
TESTING PROGRAM OF. THERE'S NEW
LEGISLATION- THAT WOULD ALTER.
HOW THAT ASSIST OCCURRED.
RESPONSE WILL ALLOW US TO BE
UPDATE THE EXIST. SYSTEM THAT
WE OR- A SYSTEM THAT IS AND I
BY THE LEAD. THIS YEAR. URGED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S. THIS
YEAR- AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
RECOVERY FROM KOBE- AND GETTING
SOMEWHERE NEAR NORMAL AGAIN- AS
WE AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
TUNNEL THIS YEAR IN BACK INTO.
SOMEWHAT NORMAL- EQUITIES ARE
HUMAN WE ALL ARE. A THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS LET'S MOVE
TO. A KIMBERLY LEAHY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DOCTOR
SANDY- JUST MENTION TO THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IS THE STATE
AGENCY THAT. GOVERNS ALL
TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND-
EDUCATOR LICENSING EXAMINATION
MATTERS- THE COMMISSION'S
OPERATIONS ARE SUPPORTED BY
EDUCATOR LICENSING AND
EXAMINATIONS BEES. I'M GOING TO
COVER IT UP PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT RELATE
TO MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT
THAT THAT MERRY SANDY JUST
MENTIONS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING WITH A
WORKLOAD BUDGET OF NEARLY
THIRTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THIS INCLUDES TWENTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IN
TEACHER CREDENTIALS FUND. SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION AND TEST
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNT FUND AND ONE POINT SIX
MILLION IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY. SPECIFIC CHANGES IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
COMMISSION INCLUDE. AN INCREASE
OF TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT YOUR
SUPPORT UPDATES TO EDUCATOR
TESTING INCLUDNG CALIFORNIA
BASIC EDUCATIONAL SKILLS TEST
THE CALIFORNIA SUBJECT
EXAMINATIONS TESTS AND A DOCTOR
SEND YOU MENTIONED THE READING
INSTRUCTION COMPETENCE
ASSESSMENT. THIS AMOUNT OF
FUNDING MAY BE SUBJECT TO
ADJUSTMENT AT THE MAY REVISION
AS THE COMMISSION FINALIZES
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS SELECTS A
RECOMMENDATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT THREE
MILLION ONE TIME REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY TO SUPPORT ACTIVITIES
OUTLINED IN THE FEDERAL
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
RENEWAL AWARD INCLUDING
DEVELOPMENTS HAVE A TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT FOR
CANDIDATES SEEKING A TEACHER
LEVEL CHILD DEVELOPMENT PERMIT.
BECAUSE IT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE COMMISSION'S
WORKLOAD BUDGET THAT REFLECT
PROJECTED TEMPORARY DECREASES
ONE CREDENTIAL AND EXAMINATIONS
REVENUES IN BOTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO DUE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN IN HAWKE'S. IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A PATHWAY
FOR CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO
DEMONSTRATE BASIC SKILLS
PROFICIENCY AND SUBJECT MATTER
COMPETENCE THROUGH SUBJECT
THROUGH EXCUSE ME THROUGH
COURSEWORK FROM A PREPARATION
PROGRAM. WITH THAT I'M AT THE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS FROM.
THANK YOU WE REALLY APPRECIATE
PRESENTATION I HAVE ONE
QUESTION A MOMENT FOR DOCTOR
SANDY BUT WHAT ME JUST SAY THAT.
THE IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR THE
STAFF TO CALENDAR THIS BECAUSE
YOU HAD TO DO THE BUDGET PART
AND THEN YOU HAD TO DO THE
POLICY PART. CAN UNDERSTAND THE
BUDGET PARK WITHOUT EXPLAINING
TO POLICY PART SO- SIX ONE THE
POLICY PART SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET AND
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL REFLECT IN
BRIEFER PRESENTATIONS ON THE
NEXT ITEM OUR OUR THAT THAT HAS
HAPPENED. IT AND MY ONE
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR SANDY EVEN
THOUGH EVERYBODY DESCRIBED WHAT
WAS IN THE BUDGET. OF DO YOU
HAVE ENOUGH REVENUES PROPOSED
TO MEET WHAT IS BEING ASKED OF
YOU IN THE TRAILER BILL.
SENATOR WITH REGARD TO THESE
PROPOSALS YES WE DO ARE THEY
BOTH SPEND CONCEPTUALIZED AS
WORK THAT WILL OCCUR WITHIN AT
THE PROGRAM LEVEL- OF SO THE
INSTITUTION SO WE'RE CREDIT THE
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO
ADMIT THESE CANDIDATES WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENACTING AND
ACTUALLY DOING THE ANALYSIS
NECESSARY TO DETERMINE IF THE
CANDIDATE IS MET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. THE COMMISSION'S
WORK IN THIS WILL BE JUST THAT
THAT THE GRANDMOTHERS AND
GUIDELINES FOR THAT ONE WE DO
HAVE THE ABILITY WITH OUR
CURRENT STAFF AND FUNDING TO
SET THIS PROGRAM UP AND IN
MOTION AND TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE CREDIT.
AS THEY AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS NEW OPPORTUNITY
NORMALLY I WOULD ASK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COMMENT
BUT I WILL JUST STIPULATE TO
DOLBY THRILLED. TO HEAR THAT
THEIR RECOMMENDATION FOR FUNDS
YOU AND THERE'S NO NEED FOR
THEM TO A SPEAK TO THEIR
PERSONAL THRILL AT- AT THAT
COMMENT. OF SENATOR. MEN DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE.
YES I HAVE A MORAL QUALMS YOUR
MIKE. YES FIVE AREA I HAD A
MORE OF A QUAL QUESTION FOR
DOCTOR SANDY- IN THEIR- AROUND
THIS TOPIC I I'VE HEARD A LOT
OF ANECDOTAL AROUND TEACHER
MORALE. AND THAT MIGHT BE
REFLECTED IN SOME OF THE
CREDENTIALING DRAFTERS IN NAP
OF COURSE CODE PLAYS A BIG PART
OF ANY BASIS- IF YOU KNOW TO
THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE MIGHT
FACE A DIFFERENT TRANSPOSE
COVERT- WILL WE SEE A SHARP
RISE IN TEACHER CREDENTIALING
REQUEST A NEW TEACHERS COMING
IN. OR ARE SHOULD WE BE
CONCERNED ABOUT TEACHER MORALE
POST CODE VISION AND MY WE
SHOULD DROP ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT IN SOME OF THE ACTIVITY
ASSOCIATED. WITH YOUR-
PARTICULAR- EMISSION. SENATOR
MAN I THINK THIS IS A VERY
FLUID SITUATION AND WE SHOULD
IN FACT EXPECT THE TEACHERS ARE
UNDER A FAIR AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
AS THE MOVE BACK INTO TEACHING
DURING COPE WITH THIS SPRING-
WE'RE ALL DEEPLY HOPEFUL THAT
WE THAT THE VACCINE WILL BE YOU
KNOW FULLY IMPLEMENTED AND
WE'LL GET BACK TO THE NORMAL
BUSINESS OF THE FALL BUT I
THINK STUDENTS FAMILIES AND
TEACHERS OF ALL NEED. THE EXTRA
MEASURE OF SUPPORT THAT WE CAN
GIVE THEM AS THEY GET BACK INTO
THAT ENVIRONMENT TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WE HEAR-
ANECDOTALLY THAT THERE ARE
TEACHERS WHO DON'T FEEL UP TO
IT AND MAY RETIRE IN MAY YOU
KNOW EARLIER THAN THEY HAD
EXPECTED- BUT WE'RE WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED ACTUALLY THIS YEAR
OF ALL YEARS THIS ACADEMIC YEAR
THAT WE'RE IN WE'RE HEARING
ANECDOTALLY FROM PREPARATION
PROGRAMS THAT ENROLLMENT IN
TEACHER EDUCATION- UP. IN
ROMANS AND HIGHER EDUCATION ARE
ARE DOWN OVERALL BUT IN ROMANS
IN TEACHER EDUCATION APPEAR TO
BE GOING UP WE'RE HEARING THAT
APPLICATION AND INTEREST IN
ENROLLMENT FOR NEXT YEAR- IS
HIGHER THAN IN PRIOR YEARS AS
WELL SO I'M VERY ENCOURAGED BY
THAT I THINK- TEACHERS THERE
ARE PEOPLE IN THE IN COMING UP
THROUGH COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WHO SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN TEACHING
AND THEIR CALL TO IT AND
THEY'RE RUNNING TOWARD IT. WELL
AND WE WANT TO GRAB HIM SHE
KEPT HIM PREPARE TO CREDENTIAL
DISCREETLY AS WE CAN'T- SO IT
IS A VERY FLUID SITUATION AND-
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN THIS SPRING IN TERMS
OF WORKFORCE THE ABILITY STAFF
CLASSROOMS BUT I'M DEEPLY
ENCOURAGED BY THOSE WHO HAVE
REALLY IMPROVED THEIR PRACTICE
I HEAR THE SITE EXCITEMENT TOO
MANY TEACHERS VOICES ABOUT THEY
CAN'T WAIT TO GET BACK WITH
THEIR STUDENTS. AND MANY OF
THEM WERE ENROLLING IN TEACHER
PREPARATION AND LOOKING FOR
WAYS IN SO I THINK THE
SITUATION. IS DEFINITELY HALF
FULL AND HALF EMPTY FROM
PERSPECTIVE. I THANK YOU FOR
THE ANSWER APPRECIATE IN. I
GUESS IF YOU HAVE ANOTHER. THAT
BECOME STATUS I YOU'RE RIGHT
THEN THANK FOR THAT ANSWER.
FROM A DATA EXTRA. HER FOR T.
UP THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS SOME
OF THE SAME PANELISTS ON
TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. AND THANK LET ME
THANK THE PREVIOUS PANEL BUT
WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE THEM AGAIN
IN THIS PANEL. THOUGH SO THIS
TIME WE HAVE KIMBERLY LEAHY
AGAIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DR SANDY AGAIN FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMISSION ONLY GARNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WE'RE ADDING AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY LEAHY. ARMINA FINANCE.
THE DEMANDS ON TEACHERS DURING
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE
BEEN INTENSE AND PRESIDENT
LEADING TO CHANGES THAT HAVE
EXACERBATED EXISTING EDUCATION
EDUCATOR SHORTAGES. THE
PANDEMIC HAS ACCELERATED
RETIREMENTS AND REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
WELL ONE CREASING THE NUMBER
TEACHER SERVING ON AN EMERGENCY
CREDENTIAL. YES ITS URGING TO
HEAR ANECDOTALLY THAT THE
PIPELINE DOES SEEM TO STILL BE
STRONG AND AT NEW CANDIDATES
ARE ENROLLING IN PREPARATION
PROGRAMS IT MINISTRATION
ESTIMATED TRUMP CREASING THE
NUMBER OF WELL PREPARED
TEACHERS IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM WELL PREPARED EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE IS A SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR SHE RUNS. AND IN CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THIS
ESPECIALLY POST PENSION AS
STUDENTS DEAL WITH THE LONG
TERM. IMPACT BUT NINETY. GIVEN
THESE CHALLENGES TOGETHER
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S TEACHER
PIPELINE. THIS INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANTS PROGRAM TO
ESTABLISH NEW OR EXPANDING
EXISTING TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND DESIGNATED
SHORTAGE DEALS ALLEN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND BUDGET CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE TEACHER
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM JUST SUPPORT
AT LEAST ONE THOUSAND FORTY
ONE. CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
AREN'T TEACHING CREDENTIAL. OF
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
PROVIDED FOR THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT STEP TO FIVE
MILLION IS AVAILABLE BURKE
CASSIDY GRANTS TO SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATIONS FOR A
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT. BUT
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN WELL
RECEIVED BY LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND HOW ARE
SIGNIFICANT UNMET DEMAND. RATE
THAT I'M HAPPY TO PASS THIS
JUNE VERY STAND I'M SURE SHE
HAS MORE TO SAY ON TALKS
GRAYSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME BACK DR CINDY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF THIS IS THIS IS
EXCITING WORK THAT WE'VE OF
BEEN GRATEFUL TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE STATE HAS INVESTED MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF PATHWAYS
AND THE AND THE SUPPORT FOR
CANDIDATES COMING INTO TEACHING
AND THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN IN FACT I
SUSPECT- AND PROBABLY SHOULD
PROVE THREE SOME REASONABLE
DATA COLLECTION THAT. THE
INCREASED ENROLLMENTS WERE SEEN
THIS YEAR ARE DUE IN PART TO
THE STIMULATION THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED THUS FAR BY THREE
STATE INVESTMENT. SOME OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- THERE WAS FOR
INSTANCE THERE'S TEN MILLION
DOLLARS SET ASIDE TO DEVELOP
UNDERGRADUATE PATHWAYS WE ISSUE
FORTY ONE GRANTS TO
INSTITUTIONS THAT CREATED.
EIGHTY OR SO DIFFERENT
UNDERGRADUATE PATHWAYS FOR
SOMEONE TO START AS A FRESHMAN
IN COLLEGE COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE UNDER CREDENTIAL WITHIN
FOUR OR FOUR AND A HALF YEARS
AND MOVE INTO TEACHING- THAT
WAS AN INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
AND NOW WE NEED TO DO IS
RECRUIT INTO THOSE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE OF THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER RATHER AVAILABLE TO
CANDIDATES LIKE TO DO THAT KIND
OF FAST TRACK UNDERGRADUATE
PROGRAM TO GET IT DONE. I SEE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM ALSO AS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM WE'RE
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PARTNER
WITH A HIGHER EDUCATION TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND MOVE THAT
PROGRAM TO THEIR CAMPUS THE
SERVER JUST GOOD TEACHER
RESIDENCY IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THAT WORK COURSES ARE OFFERED
TO THEIR TEACHERS. ON CAMPUS ON
THE AT THE SCHOOL CAMPUS OF THE
WITHIN THE L. EA WITH
OCCASIONAL FORCES BACK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF THE INSTITUTION.
AND THEIR LOCAL THE STRICT.
BONDED SIGNIFICANT TO A- TO
GROW THEIR OWN TO THROUGH REST.
AND THESE OF THE PROVIDE THE
SECOND SET OF HERE OF THE T.
NEEDS TO GET A FULL YEAR IN A
IN PREPARATION WITH VETERANS.
WILL LEARN THEIR CRAFT. THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO SUBSTITUTE IF THEY
GET A SUBSTITUTE TEACHING
CREDENTIAL SOME OF THEM MAY
EVEN SERVICE FOR PROFESSIONALS
TO PROVIDE CERTAIN KINDS OF
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. WITHIN WITHIN
THE SYSTEMS OF EDUCATION.
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IS A LONG
TERM INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TEACHERS ON OUR
END AND ELLIE A CAPACITY TO
DEVELOPING GROW AND PARTNER. IN
THE GROWTH OF THEIR OF THEIR
TEACHER FORCED THE CLASSIFIED
GRANT TO SPEND AN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. HI
RECRUITING LOCALLY PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE
SCHOOLS ALONGSIDE TEACHERS FOR
MANY YEARS WHO HAVE COMPLETED
SOME AMOUNT OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TOWARD A CREDENTIAL. THIS
PROGRAM PUTS HIM ON TRACK TO
GET ALL THE WAY TO THE FINISH
LINE TO BECOME TEACHERS WITHIN
THE DISTRICT- THESE ARE
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS IN THIS
IS NOT. I WOULD SAY A TIME TO
REDUCE OUR FOCUS OUR ENERGY.
AROUND THIS EFFORT TO BUILD OUR
CAPACITY TO DEVELOP TEACHERS
AND TO SPEND THE MONEY
NECESSARY TO RECRUIT THEM- SO
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVESTMENT
THIS YEAR- TO CONTINUE THE
RESIDENTS WHO WORK WE ARE
LOOKING AT A FIVE YEAR WINDOW
TO FULLY DISTRIBUTE THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
RESIDENCIES. AND TO HELP AT
LEAST BUILD THEIR CAPACITY TO
WORK WITH THEIR HIRING
PARTNERS. GET THAT DONE- AND
SIMILARLY I THINK- THAT THE
CLASSIFIED GRANT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN VERY POPULAR IN THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS I THINK WILL BE WELL
SPENT. TO RECRUIT MORE
TEACHERS. WE SUPPORT SUPPORT.
ADMINISTRATIONS WAS. THANK YOU-
THEN WE'LL GO TO. OUR DAILY
GARNER FOR THE OF THE- THANK
YOU CHAIR GARNER BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF MANY OF THE
TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH CTC ARM
ARE HIGHLY SUPPORTED BY THE S.
P. I. N. C. E. INVESTMENTS IN
OUR TEACHERS AN EDUCATED WORK
FORCE. WE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
ARE VITAL TO CLOSING THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP AND WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST
TEACHERS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON GETTING MALES OF TEACHERS
MALE TEACHERS OF COLOR IN THE
CLASSROOM AND TEACHERS IN THE
FIELD OF SCIENCE MATH AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION. EARLY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS HAVE MORE
THAN DOUBLED THE PROPORTION OF
TEACHER CANDIDATES OF COLOR
WHEN COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TEACHERS PREPARED IN A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM STATE OR ARE
RETAINED AT THEIR SCHOOLS AND
IN A TEACHING PROGRAM AT HIGHER
RATES. PARTICULARLY IN SCHOOLS
WITH HISTORICALLY HIGH TEACHER
TURNOVER RATES WE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THIS POINT AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN WILL MOVE TO AMY
LEE OF THE- COLONIAL. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS IMMEDIATELY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ON THE GOVERNOR'S
TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION PROPOSALS MONEY TO
SHARE OUR ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M STARTING
WITH A TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANTS
THAT GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR
ADDITIONAL GRANTS TO. ESTABLISH
NEW AND EXPAND EXISTING TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. JUST AS A
QUICK REMINDER TEACHER
RESIDENCIES BORROW FROM THE
MEDICAL RESIDENCY MODEL WHERE
TEACHER CANDIDATES TEACH
ALONGSIDE A MENTOR TEACHER. FOR
AT LEAST ONE HALF OF THE TIME
WHILE PURSUING COURSE WORK. ON
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST ESTABLISH
A TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN I SAT. IN OUR
ASSESSMENT WE FOUND TO BE
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT ART DID
YOU RESIDENTS THE MODEL TO.
IMPROVE TEACHER PREPARATION.
BUT IT CAN BE CHALLENGING TO
INITIATE AND SUSTAIN. FOR
INSTANCE THAT DISTRICTS THAT WE
SPOKE TO MENTIONED ISSUES
ESTABLISHING A RELIABLE
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
UNIVERSITY PROVIDING THE COURSE
WORK. I'M ATTRACTING RESIDENTS
TO THE PROGRAM AND FIND FINDING
SUSTAINABLE FINDING AFTER THEIR
GRANDPARENTS. ADDITIONALLY CDC
WAS ONLY ABLE TO AWARD TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION OUT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION. INITIALLY ALLOCATED
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION. DUE TO
THESE REASONS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A- REDUCED
AMOUNT OF FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANTS.
REFLECTING THEM OUT AT TTC HAS
BEEN ABLE TO WORK TO DATE. AND
THE LIKE THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROGRAMS
THAT MIGHT DAMPEN INTEREST. FOR
THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL PROGRAM OR
THE CLASSIFIED PROGRAMS- THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO PROVIDE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FOR ADDITIONAL
GRANTS TO SUPPORT. CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES SUCH AS-
TEACHERS AIDS. MUST DRIVERS
CAFETERIA WORKERS- CREDENTIAL
ALL DOUBLE PARTICIPATE K.
RECEIVE UP FIFTY FOURTHS OVER
YEARS UNDER THE PER. WE FOUND
THAT THE CLASSIFIED PROGRAM IS
IN HIGH DEMAND AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY SEVEN APPLICANTS
APPLICATIONS FROM DISTRICTS AND%
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
WERE UNDERFUNDED FROM THE FIRST
TWO ROUNDS OF FUNDING. SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR SEEMS SUPPORTIVE
OF THE PROGRAM AND CONSIDER IT
A LONG TERM GROW YOUR OWN
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGY. HOWEVER THE
CLASSIFIED PROGRAM DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE TARGETED TO
SCHOOLS MOST AFFECTED BY
TEACHER SHORTAGES. AND OUR
ANALYSIS WE FOUND THAT OF DAY
TWENTY THREE DISTRICTS THAT
APPLIED INDIVIDUALLY SEVEN HAD
LOWER SHARES OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. AND TEACHERS ON
EMERGENCY CREDENTIALS COMPARED
TO STATEWIDE AVERAGES WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AUGMENTATION TO THE
CLASSIFIED PROGRAMS. ALSO
INCLUDE CHANGES TO PRIORITIZE
AND TARGET SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE MOST AFFECTED BY
TEACHER SHORTAGES AND THIS
INCLUDES- THOSE WITH HIGHER
SHARES OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ON EMERGENCY
CREDENTIALS. THIS IS JUST
CONSISTENT WITH HOW THE STATE
TARGETS OTHER TEACHER WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES WITH THAT I'LL
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR CALL. AND UNWANTED GET
BACK TO ONE YOUR COMMENTS BUT
BUT FIRST. OUR OUR I WAS HOPING
SOMEBODY AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
THE RIGHT PERSON IS TO ASK.
COULD STAND BACK FROM THESE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS. ENTELLUS
WHAT THE PACE OF RETIREMENTS IS
BEEN IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
VERSUS THE NEED FOR NEW
TEACHERS. AND WHETHER THERE'S A
SHORTAGE THAT IS COMING FROM
THAT AND LOOKING AHEAD TO MAYBE
THE TEACHERS THAT ARE WRITTEN
THE RETIREMENT AGE FOR THE NEXT
TEN YEARS. WHAT THAT MEANS
ABOUT THE ABILITY OF US HAVING
ENOUGH TEACHERS TO COME IN
BEHIND THEM BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ALL THESE INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAMS THEY'RE GOOD AND WE
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND FULLY WHAT THE
OVERALL. SITUATION IS OF
WHETHER WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE RETIRING AT
A MUCH FASTER RATE THAN NEW
TEACHERS ARE COMING AND- I JUST
DIDN'T GET A SENSE OF THAT FROM
THE- OF THE INFORMATION I DON'T
KNOW WHO WANTS TO TAKE THAT
FIRST SHOULD I. START WITH
DOCTOR SANDY AND THEN SEE ABOUT
EITHER THE L. A. O. OR- FOR
FINANCE. YES THANK YOU- THE
ELITE SO THE COMMISSION DOES%
NOT KEEP TRACK OF REQUIREMENTS
PERCENT- WE HAVE DATA IN A IN A
REPORT SOMEWHEREAND I
CERTAINLY CAN GET THIS YEAR
THAT INDICATES THE AGE RANGES-
IN WHICH THE CURRENT POPULATION
ALL OF WHICH COULD BE AN
INDICATOR OF YOU KNOW WHEN TO
BEGIN TO PREDICT REQUIREMENTS
BUT I DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA AND
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK EITHER.
FINANCES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THE ELDERLY- IF
ANY OF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO SPEAK TO
THAT QUESTION. CHANNEL AIRED
LIKE HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT
UNFORTUNATELY CD DOESN'T
COLLECT THAT IF THAT
INFORMATION BUT I BELIEVE THAT
CAL SISTERS. MAY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION SO EIGHT I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO GO TO A
DIFFERENT AGENCY FOR THAT INFO
OKAY BUT YOU SEE IT'S REALLY
HARD. TO CONSIDER ALL THE
TEACHER TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
ASSESS THE RETIREMENTS THAT ARE
POINTED OUT HERE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HAPPENING
DURING COLD FOOD. AGAINST WHAT
THE NEED IS AND WHETHER WE'RE
FALLING SHORT AND IT. AND WHILE
I'M GOING TO LOOK AT THESE. ON
THE FACE OF IT FOR WHAT THEY
ARE WHICH IS WHICH IS OVERALL
GOOD. IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW
BEFORE MISSING A TARGET FOR
WHAT WE REALLY NEED FOR
TEACHERS AND WHETHER WE SHOULD
BE AIMING SOME OF THESE EFFORTS
NUMERICALLY TO THAT DOESN'T
TELL US. WHETHER THESE NUMBERS
ARE VALUABLE AGAINST WHAT THE
OVERALL TRENDS ARE- AND LET ME.
ASK AND I DON'T KNOW. WHETHER
IT'S FINANCE OR THE COMMISSION
WHEN THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST SAYS THAT OF THE
CLASSIFIED PROGRAMS IN HIGH
DEMAND BUT IS NOT TARGETED TO
THE AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
SHORTAGES DO EITHER OF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK TO THAT. I CAN START
AND SAY THAT THAT WASN'T IT
WASN'T. THAT'S NEVER BEEN ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE- OF
THAT PROGRAM. THE TARGET SO.
SELFISH ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
GRASS BASED ON THE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINED BY THE LEGISLATURE
WINNING THE PEACE FUNDS IN
MOTION. THIRD I GUESSED THAT
THE OUR WAY OF SAYING IT WOULD
REALLY BE DESIRABLE TO TARGETED
TO THE AREAS THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED EVEN A. N. THE L.
A. O. ARE YOU REALLY SUGGESTING
THAT SINCE THIS ISN'T ON THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ACTUALLY
CONSIDER AS A POLICY MATTER.
ADDING THAT AS A THING WHERE
WHERE IT WOULD BE TARGETED TO
THE UNDERSERVED AREAS. YES
SENATOR THAT IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION TO ADD YOUR
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PRIORITIZE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY SCHOOL DE SORRY
TEACHER SHORTAGES. KERN IF
THEY'RE GONNA GO BACK TO EITHER
FINANCE OR FOR DOCTOR SANDY IF
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO DO
THAT. DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WOULD
BE HARDFOR YOU TO IMPLEMENT.
WELL I DON'T IT'S NOT
CHALLENGING TO IMPLEMENT THAT
WE SIMPLY PUT THAT IN THE GRANT
CONDITIONS FOR RATIFICATION AND
THAT WILL LIMIT THE POOL OF WHO
APPLIES. TO RECEIVE THESE
GRANTS I DO WONDER HOWEVER
WHETHER THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME
TO DO THAT- IT'S NOT CLEAR TO
ANY OF US YET WHAT RETIREMENTS
ARE GOING TO BE LIKE THIS YEAR
BASED ON CO. WE HEAR ABOUT IT
IN THE WAY IN FACT WE DON'T I
HAVEN'T WE DON'T WE WON'T KNOW
OF. UNTIL FOR A FEW MONTHS YET.
HOW MANY TEACHERS DECIDE THAT.
THEY'RE GONNA RETIRED THIS YEAR
BASED ON CODE BASED ON ANY
NUMBER OF OTHER CONDITIONS SO
IT'S CHALLENGING AT THE MOMENT
TO KNOW WHERE THE AREAS OF NEED
ARE GOING TO BE- IS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I THINK THOUGH THAT
WHAT'S BEING POINTED OUT. IS
THAT. IT IS NOT MEETING A
DEMAND FOR THE SHORTAGES ARE
AND I THINK THAT WHEN YOU DO
THIS. YOU DON'T PRECLUDE THE
OTHERS FROM APPLYING AND
PRECLUDE THE OTHERS FROM BEING
FUNDED IT IS. IT IS JUST THAT
YOU TRY TO GO TO WHERE THE NEED
IS AND THEN. IF THE
APPLICATIONS ARE ONLY FROM
AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE
UNDERSERVED AND DID YOU. YOU
SUCCESSFULLY RANKED THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND MOVE IT OUT
THE DOOR I DON'T THINK IT'S- IT
WAS A SUGGESTION THAT IT BE.
EXCLUDED THE OTHERS IT'S JUST
IF THERE ARE. ARE HIGH NEEDS
AND- IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
DATA CHANGES YEAR TO YEAR THAT
IS ACTUALLY RELATES TO MY
PREVIOUS QUESTION WHICH IS IT
WOULD BE REALLY GOOD TO HAVE A
SENSE OF THE TRENDS BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO EFFECTIVELY. RESPOND TO THE
TREND SENATE. EVERYBODY WAS
POINTING TO ANOTHER AGENCY THAT
IS NOT HERE BUT- BUT YOU'RE THE
ONES ADDED MINISTERTHE TH THE
PROGRAMS THAT. ARE SUPPOSED TO
ADDRESS THE TRENDS SO IT WOULD
BE REALLY GOOD TO KNOW. THAT IF
THERE'S A SHORTAGE WE ARE
REALLY ADDRESSING WHERE THE
SHORTAGES. AND NOT JUST
FIGURING MARC THIS IS GOOD AND
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO THIS AND
THERE'S BOUND TO BE A SHORTAGE
SO WE NEED TO DO IT WOULD BE
NICE TO HAVE SOME. SOME DATA
THAT THAT SORT OF. COULD
ADDRESS THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
SURE- AND WE COLLECT AND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
COLLECTS ANNUALLY IN THE FALL
OF PROJECTED HIRES FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. AND WE DO
REPORT THAT IN ORDER TO JUSTIFY
REPORT EVERY YEAR- SO IT'S A
PROJECTION. AND YOU KNOW AS OUR
DATA SYSTEMS GET BETTER WILL BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
PROJECTION WAS ACCURATE OR NOT.
BUT THE PROJECTIONS WE SEE FOR
HIRING AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND
WERE PROJECTED FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY- ACADEMIC YEAR AS NEEDED
TO BE HIRED. BY DISTRICTS
REPORTED THIS ABOUT 30% OF
THOSE REFER MULTIPLE SUBJECT
TEACHERS WHO WORK PRIMARILY
INDICATE ENVIRONMENT. OF ABOUT-
10% 9% IN IN SCIENCE 9% IN
ENGLISH A SINGLE SUBJECT AREAS.
THAT 7% ACROSS THE SCIENCES-
THAT'S MORE OR LESS HOW THE%
BREAKDOWNS WERE FOR THE NUMBERS
OF TEACHERS ACROSS DIFFERENT
CREDENTIAL. TYPES IF THAT'S
HELPFUL BUT I THINK THE STATE
DOES NEED TO GET BETTER AND
WE'D LIKE TO GET BETTER AT
PROJECTING. A DEMAND. WELL WE
CAN TELL YOU A LOT ABOUT WHO'S
COMING INTO PREPARATION- AND
PEOPLE COME IN AND OUT OF
TEACHING OF FOR A WHOLE VARIETY
OF REASONS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
PART OF THE SCOPE OF OUR STUDY.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT KIND OF
DATA COLLECTION IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. MISTER MILLER I WAS
JUST ABOUT TO RECOGNIZE YOU
BECAUSE YOUR HAND TO STOP. SO
THANK THANK YOU FOR. HE RICK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE A
OF COMMENTS ON THE EAST. ARE
RESIDENTS AND- CLASSIFIED BROKE.
I'D LIKE JUST FIRST WITH THE
RED. SINCE OUR FARTHER BACK
WILL THAT OUT OF WAY BUT- LAST
YEAR. THE COMMISSION WAS ONLY
TO ALLOCATE TWENTY SEVEN. OF
THE- MONEY THAT HAD BEEN
PROVIDED FOR THAT PROGRAM. AND
THAT'S NOT DUE TO A LACK OF
DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM OR A
LACK OF. EFFORT ON THE PART OF
THE COMMISSION- HE OF HOPE AND
BUDGET CONCERNS THE MONEY FOR
THE PROGRAM WAS SWEPT. JUSTICE
THEY WERE ABOUT TO ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL GRANTS AND SO THERE
IS ALREADY WAITING APPLICATIONS
TO BE BURNED. OUT FOR THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM SO I. I HAVE
SOME CONCERN ABOUT. CUTTING THE
PROPOSAL. TO BE LESS THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION THAT IT WEEK
INCLUDED IN THAT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SO IT JUST. BUT IT
SHOULD BE THAT PROGRAM ON THAT
NOTE. AND THEN LIVING ACTUALLY.
CLASSIFIED PROGRAM. WE'RE OPEN
TO. ABOUT ADJUSTING REQUIRE.
FOR ELLIS IN THE PROGRAM- BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO. KIND OF RAISED
THE- IDEA TO THINK ABOUT IT WE
BASED ELIGIBILITY ON LET'S SAY
EXAMPLE EMERGENCYPERMITS OR
WAIVERS YOU SHOULD KEEP IN
MIND. THAT THOSE TYPES OF-
LICENSORS FOR TEACHERS TO
PROVIDE CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION
ARE TEMPORARY THEY CAN ONLY BE
ISSUED WARRANTS AND THEY'RE
KIND OF LIKE THIS LOADING
NUMBER SO A SCHOOL MAY HOW MANY
OF THOSE ONE YEAR. AND HAVE YOU
WORKED IN NEXT YEAR AND THAT'S
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND THAT-
DATE DATE COULD BE ELIGIBLE ONE
YEAR AND THEN NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
NEXT YEAR SO IT'S- LIKE I SAID
WE'RE OPEN TO A CONVERSATION
AROUND THAT BUT WE NEED TO
DEFINITELY. WORK WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE DETAILS OF
HOW THAT WOULD STRONG SHOWING
WORK IN IMPLEMENTATION. THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO ASK THANK YOU
THANK YOU I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
RAISED HANDS ON THAT SO LET ME
ASK A CENTER MENIFEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. YEAH I JUST WANTED
TO REVISIT THAT RESIDENCY
PROGRAM- ACCORDINGLY- REPORT
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE HIGH COSTS
ARE HIGH START UP COSTS. IT'S I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS YOU KNOW
WE ARE PROJECTING OUT IF I'M
RECALLING. CORRECTLY I.
SHORTFALLS IN THE BUDGET IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS OF THIS THIS-
SURPLUS THAT WE'RE SEEING THIS
YEAR. IT REALLY IS A ONE TIME
SURPLUS IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
WILL BE ONES WERE FACING MORE
CHALLENGES. GIVEN THAT THESE
PROGRAMS COST SO MUCH TO SET UP
DOES IT MAKE MORE SENSE TO
ALLOCATE OUT. SOME OF THESE
FUNDS OVER THREE FOUR YEARS
PERHAPS OR- TO DO SOMETHING
OTHER THAN COMMITTED AS ONE
TIME. ONE YEAR FUNDING. YEP
THIS IS KEN LAY HERE AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. D.
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM- IS
SPREAD OUT OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD SO IT'S ONE TIME FUNDING
ONE HUNDRED MILLION BUT IT'S
AVAILABLE OVER FIVE YEARS. SO
THE THOUGHT WOULD BE THAT
INITIALLY THE COMMISSION WOULD
BE ABLE TO SATISFY EXISTING
APPLICATIONS AND THEN PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS OVER
THE PERIOD OF THE- GRANT.
PERIOD AND THEN- THE SECOND
YEAR THE MORE GRANTS WOULD BE A
SATISFIED SO I'M I CAN LEAVE
THE DETAILS OF. OF THE DEMAND
AND THE GRANT APPLICATIONS- TO
THE COMMISSION THANK YOU. OKAY
ANY OTHER COMMENT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON THERE THANK YOU. THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MEN-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. A WHICH IS THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER PROGRAM
AND I THINK SOME OF OUR
PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS REFLECT ON
ISSUES HERE. IN THE PANEL'S
GABRIELA CHAVEZ OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JAKE
BREMNER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION ELLIE
GARNER AGAIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND AMY
WE AGAIN FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER MORE HOLD QUESTIONS
TO AFTER ALL FOR PRESENTED AND
WE'LL START WITH GABRIELA
CHILDERS. THE MORNING TRAIN
MEMBERS W. LIKE CHáVEZ WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
WILL GIVE MY COME SHORT. AS THE
AGENT I STATES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
IS FOR THE GOLDEN STATE FUTURE
GRANT PROGRAM. WHICH PROVIDES
SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS HUCAL NEED TO WORKING
IN THE HIGH NEED FEEL. I JUST
COASTLINES WITH THE HIGHEST
RATED ANON CREDENTIAL OR WAIT
FEATURES I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO CHECK FROM
HER FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND- SENATOR MEN- VERY
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU TODAY JAKE
BRUNNER DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AND EXTERNAL RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND HAPPY TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM TODAY AND REJOIN YOU ON
WEDNESDAY FOR OTHER STUDENT AID
COMMISSION BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
OTHER ITEMS. THIS TO ME
COMMISSION WELCOMES THIS
PROPOSED NEW INVESTMENT IN THE
GOLD STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
COMMISSION IS BEEN GRATEFUL FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INITIATE THIS
NEW FORM OF SUPPORT FOR
INSPIRING EDUCATORS AND
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS EXPANDING
OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE PIPELINE
IN CALIFORNIA. AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS THERE WAS
REDIRECTION OF STATE FUNDING
INITIALLY ALLOCATED TOWARDS THE
PROGRAM AND IN TWENTY TWENTY AN
ALLOCATION OF FEDERAL I. D. E.
A. FUNDING- INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES EDUCATION ACT
FUNDING THAT THIS TO MAKE
COMMISSION- WAS- ALLOCATED TO
SHIP DURING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM TO FOCUS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS AGAIN THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HAS
RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY APPLICATIONS
FROM STUDENTS- THUS FAR
INDICATING THAT THEY WILL
PURSUE. A CREDENTIAL AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION. THE
COMMISSION IS IN THE OF. AND
VALIDATING THE APPLICANT
SPECIAL EDUCATION CREDENTIALS
WITH THEIR INSTITUTIONS AND
THEN OBTAINING THE TEACHING
AGREEMENTS FROM ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. ANTICIPATE THAT THIS
PROCESS WILL CONCLUDE IN THE
NEXT WEEK OR TWO. HOWEVER THE
COMMISSION IS NOT YET ABLE TO
DISPERSE AWARDS- JUDY'S
ELIGIBLE STUDENT APPLICANTS AS
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR FINAL
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF AN INTER
AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- DUE TO THE NATURE OF
THESE FEDERAL FUNDS THROUGH THE
ID A PROGRAM. ONCE THIS
AGREEMENT HAS BEEN SIGNED OFF
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION CAN
BEGIN TO CERTIFY STUDENT
APPLICATIONS AND DISBURSE FUNDS
TO THEIR INSTITUTIONS. WE DO-
BELIEVE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE APPLICATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR BUT-
ESTIMATE THAT IT IS UNLIKELY WE
WOULD EXTINGUISH THE ENTIRE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE
BUDGET. THE REMAINING FUNDS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
ADDITIONAL WARDS IN THE
UPCOMING YEAR AND I'M HAPPY TO
SPEAK TO THE AMOUNT OF
AVAILABLE FUNDS IF- YOU SHOULD
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT
SENATOR BUT ALL ALL KEEP MY
COMMENTS THERE FOR NOW. THANK
YOU IT IS THE POSTER BEHIND YOU
ABOUT A DEER OR ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- CHAIR
LAYERED MY POSTERS BEHIND ME
ARE ACTUALLY BOTH FROM-
LIBRARIES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. AND THEN
ONE ACTUALLY FROM DOWN IN YOUR
DIRECTION FROM THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM BUT IT SAYS DEAL WE-
SERVE OUR- LIBRARY. BUT YEAH
THAT COULD BE A DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR TODAY'S PURPOSES
OKAY WELL THEN WE'LL GO WITH
THAT BECAUSE THE NEXT PERSON IS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ELLIE GARDNER. THANK
YOU FOR ANSWERING THAT RANDOM
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CHAIR I
LIKE ON ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- THE PROGRAM IS MET
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMISSION AND
CITY DOES NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD AT THIS TIME CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS WHEN
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IF YOU'RE A NEARLY FROM L. A.
L. AGAIN WE WANTED TO SHARE OUR
ASSESSMENT AND RECOMMENDATION
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
NONPROFIT NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR. ADDITIONAL GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANTS. AT THIS
TIME THE FIRST ROUND OF T.
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANTS
HAVE NOT YET BEEN AWARDED WHICH%
MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO MEASURE
THE EFFECT OF THIS PROGRAM ON
TEACHER SUPPLY. FOR THIS REASON
WE CONSIDER AN ADDITIONAL ROUND
OF FUNDING TO BE SOMEWHAT
PREMATURE. FURTHERMORE THE
IMPACT OF THIS PROGRAM ON A
DRESSING RECRUITMENT CHALLENGES
THAT LOW INCOME SCHOOLS MAY
EXPERIENCE. MAY BE LIMITED.
FIRST THERE IS NO GUARANTEE
THAT A TEACHER CANDIDATE WILL
ULTIMATELY TEACH AT A LOW
INCOME SCHOOL OR BE ABLE TO PAY
BACK GRANT FUNDING IF THEY ARE
UNABLE TO MEET THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. AND SUCH FACTORS
MAY SIMPLY BE OUT OF A
TEACHER'S CONTROL. FURTHERMORE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
FINDING AS A RECRUITMENT
INCENTIVE IS ALOLIMITED SINCE
SOME TEACHERS WOULD HAVE TAUGHT
AT A LOW INCOME SCHOOL EVEN
WITHOUT THE GRANT. LAST WEEK
SCHOOLS TARGETED UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL HAVE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FROM THE TO
FEDERAL COPY NINETEEN RELIEF
PACKAGES TOTALING. SEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY OVER THESE FEDERAL
FUNDS AS SCHOOLS HAVE A BROAD
RANGE OF OPTIONS TO. HIRE AND
RETAIN QUALIFIED AND PREPARED
TO TEACHERS INCLUDING TEACHERS
SERVICE AWARD SIGNING BONUSES
OR STUDENT DEBT PAYMENTS. HE'S
A PURCHASE MAYBE IT MORE
RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL NEEDS AND
GOALS AND SEAT TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTS THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROPOSAL. SHOULD
THE LEGISLATURE BE INTERESTED
IN AND SANTA FUNDING FOR
TEACHERS HOWEVER WE SUGGEST
FOCUSING EFFORTS ON EXPANDING
THE TOTAL SUPPLY OF TEACHERS IN
SHORTAGE AREAS. FOR INSTANCE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD INSTEAD
CONSIDER FOR TARGETING FUNING
TO EXPAND AND WILL MAKE IN THE
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AT THE UNDERGRADUATE
LEVEL WHICH DOCTOR CD MENTIONED
EARLIER- ANY OTHER SEATS
CURRENTLY OFFERED THIS ROUTE
INTO TEACHING. UNDER THIS
APPROACH THE STATE COULD
INCREASE THAT TOTAL SUPPLY
TEACHERS BY ENCOURAGING. MORE
MORE UNDERGRADUATE. STUDENTS TO
PURSUE TEACHING AND A HIGH I
NEED SUBJECT YOUR YES WHEN THE
OTHER. MIGHT MADE AFTER OTHER.
PROFESSIONS BUT THAT HAPPY TO
HAVE. CONCLUDE MY THERE AND YES
ANY QUESTION THINK. THANK YOU
ARM. LET ME JUST ASK OUR AND I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
FINANCER THE- PEOPLE WHO WANT
pWHO WANTS TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE JUST MADE BY
THE L. A- ABOUT THIS. I LIKE
HONOR THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT ACTUALLY. AB EIGHT I
WOULD SAY THE CALIFORNIA'S IN
THE MIDST OF A SEVERE AND
DEEPENING SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND THE
FIELD OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AT
LARGE HAS LONG BEEN PLAGUED BY
PERSISTENT SHORTAGES A FULLY
CERTIFIED TEACHERS. IN LARGE
PART DUE TO A SEVERE DROP IN
TEACHER EDUCATION ROMANS AND
HYDRATION FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATORS- AS A RESULT STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO HAVE THE
GREATEST NEEDS ARE FREQUENTLY
TAUGHT BY LEAST QUALIFIED
TEACHERS. AND PART OF THIS-
THIS PROGRAM DOES ADDRESS THAT
IN SPACE AND SPECIFICITY THE
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT BETWEEN
CD- SPECIFICALLY THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION VISION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. IS REQUIRED AS A
RESULT OF SB ONE SIXTEEN FROM
THE TWENTY TWENTIES BUDGET ACT-
AND THAT FIFTY NINE DOLLARS IS
FOR DEALING WITH THESE SPECIFIC
THINGS IN IN ADDITION- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS DOES PROVIDE
A HIGHLIGHT AND CALM AND A
SPECIAL. A ON THE ISSUE AND SO
IT IS IMPORTANT PIECE. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY I WILL
USE IT- SIMILAR TO OTHER OF
TEACHING GRANT PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERED
RECIPIENTS OF THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM AWARDS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
VERIFICATION OF EVERY YEAR THAT
THEY THOUGHT I DON'T FORGET IT
SCHOOL AND- THIS TO MAKE
COMMISSION WILL NEED TO. VERIFY
THAT THEY HAVE COMPLETED THOSE
FOR ALL FOUR YEARS I'M A
VERIFICATION AND THERE IS ALSO
IN THE DOCUMENTATION THAT
STUDENTS- SIGN IN THE IN THE
PROCESS OF RECEIVING THEIR
AWARD- REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY
COMPLY WITH THE TEACHING
REQUIREMENT AND THAT THEY ALSO
AGREED TO REPAYMENT OBLIGATIONS
SHOULD BE NOT MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT- WE WILL- BECAUSE
WE'VE NOT YET PAID OUT ANY
RECIPIENTS OF THIS PROGRAM THE
STUDENTS THAT WILL START TO
COLLECT VERIFICATION FORMS FROM
STUDENTS WOULD LIKELY BE MAY.
OF TWENTY TWO AND THEN WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE- FURTHER
DATA AND INFORMATION JUNE
CHáVEZ CANADIAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OTHER INTERESTED
PARTIES AROUND THE COMPLETION
RATES OF- PARTICIPANTS. IN
THEIR TEACHING REQUIRED. OUR
AND AN- ARM AND ASK. INNER
MOMENT OF SAN MEANT ANY. BUT
MAYBE TO RISK TO THAT. A WITH A
COMMON WAS GOING TO MAKE IN
CLOSING ON THIS ITEM. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THEY'RE JUST A LOT
OF MOVING PIECES TO THIS. AND
WHO ARE STAFF WILL WORK. ON
WHATEVER DATA BECOMES AVAILABLE
BY THE TIME WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THIS TO SEE IF IT
INFORMS IT UP OR DOWN BECAUSE-
LAST YEAR WAS SWEPT. NEXT YEAR
IT'S BACK BUT SOME OF IT IS ONE
TIME OTHERS A QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER. A MONEY HAS BEEN LEFT
OVER AND I THINK WE'LL WANT TO
TIE THAT ALL DOWN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH WHATEVER OUR
DECISIONS ARE WITH THE MAY
REVISE RATHER THAN. THAN ASKED
ABOUT I'M HERE BECAUSE THERE
ARE THERE MIGHT BE SOME MORE
FACTS TO COME INTO EVIDENCE
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS. SO LET ME ASK A- NO
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR MAN SO.
LET ME THANK ALL OF YOU ON THAT
PANEL WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE FIVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROPOSALS AND- AND- THAT'S A
ONCE AGAIN. KIMBERLY LEAHY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIE
GARNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN NAME AWAY FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IN
THAT ORDER. LET'S BEGIN WITH
KIMBERLY WAY. WHY BACK. EARLY
LIKE HE DEPART OF. CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS HAVE RISEN TO THE
CHALLENGES OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BY DEVELOPING AND
DELIVERING CURRICULUM IN A
DISTANCE LEARNING OR HYBRID
CONTEXT PROVIDING INTENSIVE AND
TARGETED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
IN SMALL GROUPS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS MOST DISADVANTAGED BY
DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ADDRESSING THE CUTE NEED TO
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING ELEVATED LEVELS OF
STRESS AND ECONOMIC GAINS IN
SECURITY. EDUCATORS AND
STUDENTS WILL FACE A WIDE RANGE
OF CHALLENGES PERCENT RETURN TO
IN CLASS INSTRUCTION. IT
MINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING EDUCATORS WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED BUT IN THE
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
COMPREHENSIVE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE FOR
EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. WITH EMPHASIS ON
DEVELOPING QUALITY TRAINING IN
HIGH NEED AREAS AND PROVIDING
TIMELY ACCESS TO TRAINING. THE
CIVICALLY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS PROVIDED IN
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
CITY CERTIFICATED AND OTHER
CLASSROOM STAFF FOCUSED AND SIX
SPECIFIC AREAS THAT ARE
IMMEDIATELY RELEVANT GIVEN THE
ACADEMIC AND EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES CREATED BY THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THESE FOCUS
AREAS INCLUDE IMPROVING
LITERACY ACROSS ALL SUBJECT
AREAS XCELERATED LEARNING AND
RE ENGAGING STUDENTS THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL WELL BEING
OF BOTH STAFF AND STUDENTS.
READING SCHOOL CLIMB. EXCLUSIVE
PRACTICES AND ENGLISH LEARNERS
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOP MUST
BE CONTENT FOCUSED INCORPORATE
ACTIVE LEARNING SUPPORT
COLLABORATION. AND USE MODELS
OF EFFECTIVE PRACTICE PROVIDE
COACHING AND EXPERT SUPPORT
OFFER FEEDBACK AND REFLECTION
WE HAVE A SUSTAINED DURATION
AND US APPLICABLES BE ALIGNED
TO THE STATE'S ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS. PARTMINER DEDICATION
WILL ALLOCATE FUNDING BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT CLASSROOMS STAFF IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH
WILL FACILITATE A RAPID
DISBURSEMENT OF THE OF THE-
FUNDS BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. THE
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVE BLOCK GRANT
WAS WELL RECEIVED BY LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
EDUCATORS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FISCAL YEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL OF
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND WILL ALLOW
EDUCATORS TO EITHER SUPPLEMENT
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
WITHIN THE SPECIFIC TOIC
AREAS. FOR SPECIFIC
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
EDUCATORS CAN USE THE FUNDS FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
MEET THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
BUDGET PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES.
FIFTEEN MILLION SHE'S. EXCUSE
ME FIFTEEN MILLION FOUR. ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO CREATE
STATEWIDE RESOURCES AND PROVIDE
TARGETED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES JUST
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY THIS INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO AWARD GRANTS TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO FUND
SCHOOLWIDE AND DISTRICTWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SERVICES ARE
PRACTICES APPLYING TO THE MULTI
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
FRAMEWORK DEVELOPED UNDER THE
SCALE UP M. T. S. S. STATEWIDE
PROJECT. IT ALSO INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION FOR ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND THE- BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO DEPART TO PARTNER
WITH ANOTHER ENTITY TO CREATE A
CENTRALIZED SET OF RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE ONGOING TRAINING AND
COACHING FOR EDUCATORS AND
SUPPORT BELLY AS IN SEVERAL KEY
AREAS INCLUDING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES- EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION FOR THE
EARLY EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FOR THE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE THE FUNDS INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
BACK FOR THE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE FOR AVAILABLE
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT OF
RESOURCES AND INITIAL INPUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR EDUCATORS OF
STUDENTS PRE K. THROUGH GRADE
THREE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL OF EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION. IS AVAILABLE OVER
THREE YEARS FOR THE COUNTY
FRESNO CA FOR THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION- TO DELIVER
THE EARLY MACINNES SHOULD TO
AND TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE
WEBSITE THE APPLICATIONS AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING IN
MATHEMATICS STRATEGIES FOR
TEACHERS OF YOUNG CHILDREN PRE
K. THROUGH GRADE THREE. TO THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
SUPPORT. THE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING PROVIDED BY THE EARLY
MATH INITIATIVE IS CONTENT
FOCUSED INCORPORATES ACTIVE
LEARNING SUPPORTS COLLABORATION
USES MODELS AFFECTED PRACTICE
PROVIDES COACHING AND EXPERT
SUPPORT OFFERS FEEDBACK AND
REFLECTION IS A SUSTAINED
DURATION. MISALIGNED TO THE
STATE'S ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS
COMPLETED INITIAL RESOURCES
DEVELOPMENT AND PILOT OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR THE
EARLY MAPPING ISSUE TOO. WITH
THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PREPARED.
PROVIDING THE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING RESOURCES TO MORE
EDUCATORS. FAMILY STATEWIDE.
WELL THE GOVERNOR'S IS FOR ONE
TIME TO FIND THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS
SUBMITTED A PLAN THAT WOULD
REQUIRE ON GOING FUNDING IF
THERE'S A DESIRE TO SATISFY THE
UNMET DEMAND FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE. TEACHER
FAMILY MATERIALS AND SUPPORT.
AND- THE SECOND PLEASE YOUR
COMMENTS L. I. I LOST MY PLACE
HERE I THINK WE DID THAT YOU'VE
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF GOING
TO THE BUDGET WE HAVE ALL THAT
INFORMATION AND I KNOW YOU
GOING THROUGH IT HELPS THE
PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME THAT
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE STAFF
REPORT. BUT WE'RE STARTING TO
RUN LOW ON TIME SO I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT IN CASE ANYBODY HAS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND THEN
GO TO ELLIE GARNER OF FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU CHAIR. ALI GARNER AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION THE CITY IS PLATE
PLEASED TO SEE THE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS IN OUR TEACHERS AN
ADDICT EDUCATOR WORK FORCE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WITH OUR
STUDENTS FACING THE CHALLENGES
OF THIS PANDEMIC IT IS CRITICAL
THAT OUR TEACHERS AND STAFF ARE
PREPARED IN THE AREA OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES TO HELP.
STUDENTS BOTH EMOTIONALLY AND
MENTALLY WE HAVE TWO ISSUES TO
NOTE ONE THE CITY APPRECIATES
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION. FOR
THE EARLY MATH INITIATIVE
PROGRAM THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IS NEEDED TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS IN REACHING AND
REACHING STATE MATH STANDARDS
THESE FUNDS. HAVE BEEN USED TO
BUILD EDUCATOR KNOWLEDGE
ENTHUSIASM AND COMFORT IN
TEACHING MATH. AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE COACHING. AND ONE ON
ONE MATH STRATEGIES. AND
FUNDING COULD ALLOW THE
INITIATIVE TO MAINTAIN AND GROW
ITS REACH AND FURTHER IMPROVE
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT. THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY COULD ALSO
SUPPORT ONLINE MODULE
DEVELOPMENT FOR ADDITIONAL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. IN
ADDITION TO THE IN PERSON AND
ZOOM VIRTUAL TRAINING. THE
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE HAS
SERVED OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN FROM AGES FROM BIRTH
TO AGE EIGHT. THROUGH THIRTY
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
EDUCATOR PART AND MORE THAN
FOURTEEN HUNDRED EDUCATORS
PARTICIPATED IN THE INITIATIVE.
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS 93%
SERVE CHILDREN THAT ARE DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND EIGHTY
NINE PERCENT. SERVE CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES WHILE THE
FORMULA VALUATION AT. DISNEY
WHILE THE FORMAL EVALUATION OF
THIS PROGRAM HAS NOT BEEN
FINALIZED. INITIAL FEEDBACK
FROM PARTICIPANTS HAS BEEN HAVE
BEEN VERY POSITIVE. THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SHOULD ALSO
SUPPORT STATE LEVEL CAPACITY TO
BROADEN THE REACH OF THE EARLY
MATH INITIATIVE AMONG THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL AND
OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GAINS. IN
PRESCHOOL OUR LEVERAGE AND
SUSTAINED IN THE EARLY GRADES.
SPECIFICALLY THE L. CD WOULD
NOTE THAT THE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE WORKLOAD AT CDP WAS
ABSORBED BY THE EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE DIVISION. BUT THE
STAFF PERSON WHO HAS BEEN THE
LEAD ON THIS PROGRAM IS SLATED
TO TRANSITION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
DUE TO THE TRANSITION OF CHILD
CARE TO SEE. THE EIGHTY ACCESS.
AS A RESULT CDP WOULD NEED AN
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO ADMINISTER
THIS PROGRAM. IF ADDITIONAL
FUNDS ARE PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
THE ONLY OTHER ITEM THAT WE
WOULD NOTE IS THAT THIS THE S.
S. P. I. N. C. E. ARE VERY
PLEASED. TO SEE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS. TOWARD
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
SUPPORT. OF ETHNIC STUDIES IN
OFFERING NEW AND EXPANDED
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES WE ARE
CURRENTLY REVIEWING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON
FINANCE FOR CLARIFICATION. AND
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS. ACT
INCLUDES CITIES REMARKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. EMILY. FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. IN
THE REMOTE ALWAYS. ON THE
GOVERNOR COMPRESS DOUBLE PROPOS.
WE JUST HAVE SOME GENERAL
ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER. FIRST WE CONSIDERED
THE GOVERNOR'S BLOCK GRANT
APPROACH TO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO BE REASONABLE.
FUNDING CAN BE USED TO
COMPENSATE STAFF TIME SPENT ON
TRAINING OR OTHER SECEDED
COSTS. AT THE BLOCK GRANT ALSO
ALLOW SOME FLEXIBILITY OVER THE
TRAINING TOPICS AS WELL
ALLOWING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO BE TARGETED TO
AREAS. THAT WOULD MOST BENEFIT
TEACHERS AND OTHER STAFF IN
EACH SCHOOL. SECONDLY MOST OF
THE TARGETED PROPOSALS ADDRESS
SPECIFIC GAPS IN TRAINING. FOR
INSTANCE THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IS DUE TO ADOPT A NEW
ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM
BY THE END OF MARCH. THIS IS
GUIDANCE IS NEW STATE FUNDED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SEEMS
REASONABLE. OTHER PROPOSALS
SEEM TO ADDRESS A LACK OF
EXISTING RESOURCES SUCH AS THE
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE OR
FURTHER PROMOTES LESS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. I'M
SUCH AS THE SEEDS CONTINUED
EFFORTS ON THE MULTI TIERED
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND YES ASK.
OR IN SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
WE ARE LESS CLEAR HOWEVER AND
HOW THE FUNDING FOR THE SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECTS WOULD ADDRESS
EXISTING GAPS. FOR INSTANCE
THAT TWO MILLION PROVIDED TO
THE SUBJECT MATTER PROJECTS FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES APPEARS
DUPLICATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OTHER PROPOSAL ON ETHNIC
STUDIES. THIRD IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTAINS VERY
FEW DETAILS ON SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS. FOR IT SINCE THE
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE ANSWER
THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
PROPOSALS DO NOT SPECIFY THE
TYPE OF ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD
BE SUPPORTED WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. THAT SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT- PROPOSAL ALSO DOES
NOT. CLARIFY HOW THE ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION WOULD BE USED
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE ON GOING
FINDING THEIR PROGRAM CURRENTLY
RECEIVES. TO ENSURE THAT FUNDS
ARE SPENT AS INTENDED WITH THE
DESIRED OUTCOMES WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CLEAR
DELIVERABLES AND EXPECTATIONS
TIED TO FUNDING FOR THESE MORE
TARGETED PROPOSALS. LASTLY WE
JUST NOTE THAT- FUNDS PROVIDED
THROUGH THE TEAM FEDERAL COUPLE
NINETEEN FEDERAL RELIEF
PACKAGES. COULD ALSO BE USED ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER HOW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS COMPLEMENT. BE SIGNS
I'M WITHOUT HELPING CLICK MY
COMMENTS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH- I WAS TO. ASKER RELATED
WHAT THE L. A. O. JUST SAID IN
ASCOT OF FINANCE WHICH IS IT IS
THERE ANY INTENT TO USE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT'S COMING AND TO
COMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS.
LET'S JUST A THEY CAN LAY HE
WENT TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO GET MUCH OF THE- FEDERAL
FUND THAT FUNDS THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED DUE TO CULTIVATE- ARE
BEING USED BY ELLIE ACE FOR
PURPOSES OTHER THAN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THEY
HAVE MANY NEEDS RIGHT NOW
DURING THE SENATE PRESIDENT AT
TIMES AND- THAT IS PART OF THE
REASON WHY WE ARE. PROPOSING SO
MUCH MONEY FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT- THERE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL NEED FOR TEACHER.
RADIATION AND TEACHER
DEVELOPMENT IN IN THESE AREAS
TO SUPPORT. STUDENTS AND DURING
THESE TIMES- I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT TO YOU FOR JUST
BEFORE YOU GO ON TO THAT
COMMENT LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE- HE DID NOT
FUNDING THAT CAME. WAS SIGNED.
WHENEVER THAT WAS LATE DECEMBER
EARLY JANUARY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND I'M NOT GONNA GET THE
NUMBERS RIGHT. IT WAS ROUGHLY
SIX POINT SEVEN OR SIX POINT
NINE BILLION TO CALIFORNIA I
THINK SIX BILLION WENT DIRECTLY
TO TITLE ONE SCHOOLS AND DIDN'T
PASS THROUGH THE STATE. BUT
THERE WAS SOME DISCRETIONARY
MONEY IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU DON'T THINK
ANYTHING WITHIN THAT IS A
CANDIDATE TO COMPLEMENT THIS
THESE PROGRAMS. ELEAZAR HOW THE-
TO USE THESE FUNDS TO
COMPLEMENT THE OTHER ROWING
THOSE AS BUT I'M I'M SAYING
THAT THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THAT COMES THROUGH THE STATE
THAT THE STATE WILL HAVE TO
APPROPRIATE AND- AND- I'M
GATHERING FROM YOUR COMMENT.
YOU'RE SAYING SHOULD BE ANY OF
THE L. A. L. L. E. AS THAT GOT.
FEDERAL MONEY THAT SHOULD USE
THAT TO COMPLIMENTED IT SHOULD
NOT BE ANY OF THE DISCRETIONARY
MONEY THAT CAME THROUGH THE
STATE. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T CATCH
THE END OF THE- THERE'S
DISCRETIONARY MONEY THAT CAME
THROUGH THE STATE AND YOU SAY
THEY CAN USE FEDERAL MONEY TO
DO IT AND NOT EVERY DISTRICT IS
A TITLE ONE DISTRICT. AND WE
HAVE DISCRETIONARY MONEY IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND I AM ASKING IF WHEN YOU SAY
THEY SHOULD JUST USE FEDERAL
MONEY. THAT YOU'RE NOT
CONSIDERING IN ANY WAY THE
DISCRETIONARY MONEY THAT PASSES
THROUGH- IS A VERY SMALL PIECE
OF THAT WOULD BE USEFUL FOR
THIS PURPOSE. I AM NOT PREPARED
TO SPEAK ON THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANY DETAILS ON THAT- AND THEN.
NO NEED FOR YOU TO TAKE MORE
WORDS THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE
DETAILS BUT IT BUT IT'S LIKE I
WOULD JUST SAY IT'S SOMETHING
WE SHOULD CONSIDER HEADING
TOWARD. OF THE MAY REVISE
GIVENS- WHAT THE L. A. O. SAID
YOU'RE GOING TO GOING TO
ANOTHER POINT. YES IT **** AMY
LEE MENTIONED. THAT SHE NOTICED
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS WERE
DUPLICATIVE OR COVERED THE
SAME. AREAS AND THIS
SPECIFICALLY DOLLARS RELATED TO
THE ETHNIC STUDIES AND I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT. TYPES OF
MONEY. FOR THE ETHNICS. ONE IS
TO GUARD SUCH MATTER. ARE OF
FUNDING AND THAT SUPPORT CLASS
NETWORKS K. TWELVE TEACHERS AND
UNIVERSITY FACULTY OVER A
SUSTAINED PERIOD OF TIME- TO
DEVELOP TEACHER SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE IN PROVIDING ETHNIC
STUDIES WELL THE OTHER-
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING WOULD GO
TO A COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
THAT WOULD CREATE. SOME
RESOURCES AVAILABLE STATEWIDE
TO ALL ELLIE AS GIVEN THAT HE-
CALIFORNIA'S SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS NOT. PROPERTY FREE OF
CHARGE TO ALL ELLIE AS FINALLY
TO SOME ELEAZAR OTHER AT LEAST
HAVE TO PAY FOR TEACHERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECTS MAN BEFORE I
ASKED SENATOR MENIFEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS- MS. LEE DO YOU HAVE
ANY RESPONSE TO THAT. YOU'RE A
LEYVA LEN I THINK WERE JUST
MENTION THAT I. THESE DETAILS
FOR THIS SUBJECT MATTER
PROPOSALS AB WASN'T REALLY MADE
CLEAR TO US SO HAPPY TO REVIEW
ANY DETAILS THAT I DEPARTMENT
FINANCES ABLE TO OFFER I THINK
IN GENERAL ARE COMMENTS EARLIER
COMMENT STANDS THAT WE THINK.
PROVIDING CAD PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON I THINK STUDIES
THROUGH DATA UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS AND THEN SEPARATELY
THROUGH A S. C. O. T. I THINK
IS RATHER DUPLICATIVE. GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH IN ORDER MOVE ON
TO. A SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE- JUST
ONE- SO I'M I'M PROUD TO NOTE
THAT THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY IN MY DISTRICT. UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF
SUPERINTENDENT ON THE HARNESS I
HAVE BEEN PART OF THE TO COUNTY
SPEARHEADING THE EMPTY SS
PROJECT- I GUESS MY QUESTION
AND I YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
HOLISTIC LEARNING. WHEN IN OUR
SOCIETY WE TALK ABOUT EACH Q.
AS BEING JUST AS IMPORTANT AS I
Q. YOU KNOW I AM REALLY
HEARTENED BY THE GOALS OF THIS
PROGRAM BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS. WHY ARE WE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT STEPS DO WE NEED TO TAKE
TO REALLY IMPLEMENT A MORE
RAPID STATEWIDE ADOPTION OF
THIS- AND SHOULD WE BE LOOKING
ORE DOES A STATEWIDE APPROACH
AND EMPHASIZING THAT RATHER
THAN SOMEONE OF THE PIECEMEAL
APPROACH WE HAVE NOW. AND I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. ARE WE GONNA HAVE
A STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION I THINK THAT
WILL NEED TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT PARTICULAR QUESTION- YOU
CAN COULD YOU GIVE ME A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR THEIR- YOU COULD JUST AS
FAR AS YOU KNOW IN TALKING
BRIEFLY WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT
MAHAR AS I THINK. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY VERY HAPPY TO
BE SPEARHEADING THIS BUT- THEY
WERE HOPING AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL HOPING FOR I WOULD
CERTAINLY BE HOPING FOR JUST.
THINKING MORE AMBITIOUSLY ABOUT
HOW WE ADOPT THE STATEWIDE AND
I KNOW WE'VE GOT A LEARNING
MODULE IN PLACE NOW- BUT WHAT
SORT OF FUNDING WOULD WE NEED
WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS WE NEED
TO REALLY MOVE THIS MORE
AGGRESSIVELY INTO STATEWIDE.
PROGRAM RIGHT. HE SENT AN
ACTUALLY GONNA DIFFER I HAVE
WITH ME BARBARA MURCHISON WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE EDUCATOR
ASK WHAT. EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE
AND EQUITY DIVISION HERE IT'S
EASY TO OVERSEE THESE PROGRAMS
FINING. THANK YOU. HI GOOD
MORNING- GARBER MURCHISON
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- WHERE
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF ED AND-
YOU COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
TO SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF OUR STATEWIDE AND TSS.
SCALING UP- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE FOURTH INVESTMENT. IN THIS
PROGRAM THE FIRST ONE WAS JUST
BUILDING A FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT
CALIFORNIA M. TSS MODEL MIGHT
LOOK LIKE. MAKING SURE THAT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY OFFICES WERE
SUPPORTED. TO UNDERSTAND THAT
MODEL AND SUPPORT THEIR
DISTRICTS HALF OF CALIFORNIA
ELEAZAR PARTICIPATED IN
TRAINING AND RECEIVE FUNDS. TO
BEGIN WORK TO SHIFT. THEIR
THEIR PARADIGM FOR HOW WE
SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA M. TSS MODEL. THAT
FIRST TWO. YEARS OF INITIAL
INVESTMENT. KIND OF BROUGHT. A
GOOD BASELINE TO THE STATE. FOR
WHAT THIS COULD LOOK LIKE. M.
THE THIRTY OF INVEST REALLY
MORE AT DISPROPORTIONATE ALITY
AROUND SUSPENSIONS AND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. AND AS NOTED- THE
DEPARTMENT ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF ED AND BUTTE
COUNTY OFFICE OF ED IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH UCLA CENTER
FOR TRANSFORMATION OF SCHOOLS
IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING
RESOURCES AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TRAININGS AND
PILOTING WITH A SET OF
DISTRICTS AROUND HOW SCHOOL
CLIMATE CAN BE SUPPORTED. TO
ADDRESS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
SPECIFICALLY SO NOW WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSED INVESTMENT- WORLD WILL
BE BUILDING OUT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH ORANGE COUNTY AND BUTTE
COUNTY. ANOTHER SET OF
RESOURCES MORE SPECIFICALLY TO
DIVE DEEPER INTO THE S. E. L.
PORTION OF THE CALIFORNIA MTS
THIS FRAMEWORK WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN. IMPACTED IN
THE THAT THE POLITE WAY OF
SAYING IT THERE'S A LOT OF A
RIPPLE EFFECT AROUND THE
PANDEMIC FOR THE LAST YEAR WE
KNOW THE DEMAND FOR SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORTS HAS.
INCREASED SO I THINK WHAT WE
SEE AS WE'RE PHASING IN AND
LAYERING ON ADDITIONAL AREAS OF
FOCUS TO SHORE UP AND PROVIDE
OUR EDUCATORS AND DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE. WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND
TRAINING- ON VARIOUS ELEMENTS
OF THE M. T. S. S. MODEL- EACH
YEAR SO I'M NOT SURE IF THE
REQUEST IS THAT I'M I'M WITH-
MY COLLEAGUE ELLIE GARNER
AROUND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT'S REQUESTED BUT
THIS KIND OF PHASED IN.
APPROACH TO BUILD ON THE
CALIFORNIA M. TSS MODEL
INCREASING CAPACITY OF ALL OF
OUR DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS WE GO-
ACTUALLY IS WELCOMED AND MAKES
GOOD SENSE TO US. GOT IT I WILL.
THE QUITE A PROCESS THANK YOU
OKAY THAT SOUNDS FIVE SENATOR
MAN WE THANK THE PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GRANT
PROGRAM WAS MY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE
GARNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MICHAEL OFFERED US
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE LET'S GO IN THAT ORDER
AND BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE MORNING TURN
MEMBERS AT LEAST MY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO THE BUDGET
PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
EXPAND UPON. THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT TO
HOLISTICALLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN.
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS OFFER A
UNIQUE MODEL TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDE INTEGRATED EDUCATIONAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO STUDENTS WAS A
WRITER WIDE RANGE OF NEEDS.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS VERY
SIMILAR TO EXISTING LANGUAGE
AROUND THE PROGRAM WITH THE
CUTE DITION DAS FUNDS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. AS WELL AS EXPANDING
AND ENHANCING EXISTING
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL GROUNDS WHAT
SUPPORT LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS TO
IMPLEMENT THE PILLARS OF THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL WHICH
ARE PROVIDING INTENSIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. OFFERING
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME AND
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
DEVELOPING COLLABORATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATORS AND OFFERING SUPPORT
FOR FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT- UP 21% OF THE
ALLOCATION CAN BE USED FOR
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS WHO
WANT TO EXPAND OR ESTABLISH
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCHWILL
MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU CHAIR. OF
THE GOVERNOR AND WE HAVE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE SCHOOLS ARE
ONE OF THE S. S. P. I.'S
PRIORITIES AND HE HAS DONE
SIGNIFICANT WORK IN THIS SPACE
I NEARLY BECAUSE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
THE WHOLE CHILD INCLUDING
MENTAL AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE ANDOTHER KEY AREAS.
SCHOOLS CAN USE THIS INTEGRATED
APPROACH TAKE INCREASE ACCESS
TO NURSES COUNSELORS AND SCIAL
WORKERS READING PLACES WHERE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES THEY NEED TO
CLOSE THE OPPORTUNITY GAP. LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDED THE
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM C. S. P. P.
GRANT. THE CITY RECEIVED A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND TWO
APPLICANTS WITH THE TOTAL ASK
OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OR
THREE HUNDRED AND 76% OF TOTAL
FINES. THE CDC WILL ANNOUNCE
PRELIMINARY WORK SHORTLY BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THE GRANT
PROCESS WAS VERY COMPETITIVE
WITH A SCORE OF EIGHTY NINE OUT
OF A HUNDRED SERVING AS THE CUT
OFF FOR GRANTEES. TWENTY
APPLICANTS WERE SELECTED AS
GRANTEES AND THESE GRANTEES
WERE MADE OF CONSORTIUMS AMSINGLE SCHOOLS WITH AWARDS
RANGING FROM THREE HUNDRED
NINETY SIX THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. IT IS CLEAR
THAT THE DEMAND FOR FUNDS WAS
AND IS SGNIFICANTLY GREATER
THAN THE FUNDS PROVIDED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WE ARE EXCITED TO
SEE THE FUNDING THIS YEAR AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE DEMAND
WILL BE MUCH HIGHER UNDER THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL. BECAUSE THE
PREVIOUS ROUND OF FUNDING WAS
LIMITED TO EXISTING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS THAT IS NOT THE CASE
WITH THIS NEW FUNDING SO WHEN
COUPLED WITH THE INCREASE
TIMELINE FOR USING THE FUNDS.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WILL
BE EVEN GREATER DEMAND FOR THIS
NEW ROUND OF FUNDING. I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY P. CALLAS AND
THESE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER TRANSITIONS
VISION TO ADDRESS ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NOW. WILL MOVE TO THE LA O'S
OFFICE. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
MICHAEL FINISHED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE WANTED TO SHARE OUR THREE
CONCERNS AND SO ALSO SEE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MODIFY THIS
PROPOSAL. OUR FIRST CONCERN IS
RELATED TO THE STATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE REQUIREMENTS-
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
COMMUNITIES SCHOOLS TEND TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH POSITIVE
STUDENT ASK WELCOMES HOWEVER
SUCCESSFUL ADOPTION REQUIRES
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES THAT CAN BE
COMPLICATED FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IMPLEMENT. DISTRICTS
WITHOUT PRIOR EXPERIENCE
OPERATING COMMUNITIES CLOSE MAY
NEED HELP LEARNING HOW TO
DEVELOP EXTERNAL PARTNERSHIPS
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND IDENTIFY ONGOING
FUNDING STREAMS IMPLEMENT AND
SUSTAIN THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
MODEL. REALIZATION IS NOT
SPECIFY HOW THE STATE WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND YOU KNOW THE RESTAURANT
GRANTS PROVIDE IN THE CURRENT
YEAR OR IN THE BUDGET YOUR
PROPOSAL. OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CITY IS IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A PLANT AND
CHRYSOSTOM'S THE PROVIDER FOR
THE FIRST FUNDING GRANTS.
HOWEVER SINCE THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE SECOND ROUND OF GRANTS
INCLUDING A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THAT MAY BE MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EXISTING ONES.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
SET SPECIFIC EXPECTATIONS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AT A
MINIMUM WE RECOMMEND THE STATE
IN THE CLOSEST AND BE AVAILABLE
TO ASSIST SCHOOLS WITH.
CONDUCTING A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
MRS ESTIMATE. THE IMPROVING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT CREATING
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
DEVELOPING. SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCES. AMERICA THAT THIS IS
THE AVAIL FOR US. APPLICANTS
AND GRAMS IF WE- OUR SECOND
CONCERN IS WITH THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- AT THE STATE IN
ORDER FOR THE STATE SUPPORT
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS ABLE TO SET
ASIDE UP TO ONE PERCENT. OF THE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE SPECIFIC THAT THE CLOSEST
OUR REQUIREMENTS ARE DISCUSSED
WOULD REQUIRE SPENDING MORE
THAN 1% OF THE PROGRAM. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
INCREASING THE AMOUNT THAT CAN
BE SET ASIDE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. OF THE PROPOSED
GRANT WOULD PROVIDE ABOUT TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT COULD
BE SPENT OVER FOUR YEARS. OUR
BUS SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND PER YEAR. THIS IS
SOMEWHAT HIGHER THAN THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
AVAILABLE OVER ONE YEAR UNDER
THE CURRENT ROUND OF GRANTS- TO
ASSESS WHETHER THAT AMOUNT IS
SUFFICIENT THE LEGISLATURE
CAPACITY YOU NEED TO REPORT IN
THE SPRING ON WHETHER THEY WANT
TO NICKEL SYSTEMS AVAILABLE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THE FIRST ROUND OF GRANTEES.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW HOWEVER THAT
SINCE THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES.
NEW COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WHERE THE
FRENCH GROUNDED NOT THERE WILL
LIKELY BE MORE NEED FOR DEBT
SUBSTANTIAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF GRANTS. OUR THIRD. IS THAT
TRANSLATION. TO PUT IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AT A
DISADVANTAGE. THE PHARMACIST IN
THE TRAILER LANGUAGE IS THE
SAME AS THE FIRST UNDERGRADS.
AND INCLUDES THINGS SUCH AS
HAVING COMMITTED MATCHING FUNDS
FOR PEOPLE SERVICES. HAVING A
PLAN FOR ASSISTING THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL SERVICES DR
GRANT RATIONS. IS CRITERIA PUT
EXISTING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT
ARE FARTHER ALONG IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND AN
ADVANTAGE OVER NO COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. TO ENSURE GRANTS WERE
AWARDED TO APPLICANTS
INTERESTED IN ESTABLISHING A
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE SPENT FUNDING
IN TWO SEPARATE GRANTS. ONE FOR
EXPANDING EXISTING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. AND ONE FIRST
ABORIGINAL COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
THIS APPROACH FOR EXPAND THE
MODEL MORE EQUITABLY ACROSS THE
STATE. AND ENSURE FUNDING CAN
BENEFIT COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
WRITE MORE. COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES THAT OUR STUDENTS. THE
COULD CAN PUSHING BACK OUT.
DEADLINE FOR THOSE SEEKING TO
ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS TO LATER
IN THE FISCAL YEAR. THIS WOULD
GIVE AT LEAST MORE TIMES SICK
THANK MORE SYSTEMS. AND
PROVIDE- SORRY TO DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS PARTS APPLICATION
DEADLINE. IS ROLLER COMMON
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I APPRECIATE EVERY CAR- MORE
SORT OF SHORT ON SO I THINK I'M
GOING TO NOTE LA OWES COMMENTS
AGAINST THIS AND WILL TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT THEM. ARE GOING
TOWARD- OF. THE MAY REVISED A
SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE NO
QUESTION SO LET ME THANK THE
PANEL. AND WE WILL MOVE TO-
ISSUE SEVEN. A WHICH IS THE
OTHER BUDGET PROPOSALS AND BILL
LANGUAGE. AND ON THIS PANEL BE
MORE SICKENING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MICHAEL
AFFAIRS AGAIN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND NOW WE GARNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
LISTENING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I'M IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'LL JUST QUICKLY RUN
THROUGH THE REMAINING BUDGET
TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS. AS
DISPLAYED IN ON THE AGENDA ON
PAGES TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
SIX THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES THREE POINT ONE
MILLION IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR THE FOURTH YEAR COST
OF THE STANDARDIZED ACCOUNT
CODE STRUCTURE SYSTEM
REPLACEMENT PROJECT. AND FOUR
MILLION IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR SPECIAL OLYMPICS OF
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS- WE HAVE ALSO PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
CLARIFY CHANGES TO THE PROCESS
BY WHICH COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION- BUDGETS ARE
CERTIFIED AND OVERSEEN BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. A LANGUAGE TO
CHANGE THE MAXIMUM REPAYMENT
HERE IN FOR FUNDS OWED BY
DISTRICTS TO SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAMS FROM FIVE YEARS TO
TWENTY YEARS. ALIGNING WITH THE
REPAYMENT PERIOD FOR WORKING
EMERGENCY APPORTIONMENT.
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONTROL OVER THAT LEGISLATION
PROCESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WHEN WE FIX. WHICH PROGRAMS
ADULTS AT CHARTER SCHOOLS COULD
GENERATE LCI FAST REQUIRE
DOCUMENTATION TO VERIFY THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND GRANDFATHERS
AND SCHOOLS CURRENTLY SERVING
ADULTS THAT HAVE BEEN MEETING
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE STATUTE
TO BE CAPPED AT THEIR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY.
FUNDING LEVEL. ADDITIONALLY
WE'VE ALSO PROPOSED LANGUAGE
THAT REVISES THE CALCULATION OF
PENALTIES ASSOCIATED WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING ATTENDANCE-
ADJUSTMENTS TO FUNDING
CALCULATION FOR PIONEER UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND PARADISE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BROUGHT ABOUT PROVIDE FUNDING
RELIEF RELATED TO NATURAL
DISASTERS. LANGUAGE TO SUSPEND
THE CALCULATION OF ALLOCATING
CHARTER SCHOOL EIGHTY EIGHT TO
A SPONSORING SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. AND LANGUAGE TO
REDUCE FUNDING APPORTIONED TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR. I'M WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND I ALSO HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- THAT I MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO ANSWER ON THE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS JUST
MENTIONED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
FOLIO. WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
COMMENTS FOR NUMBER HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO TO ONLY
GARNER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU CHAIR I
LIKE ON ON THE OTHER STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION I'LL KEEP MY
REMARKS BRIEF AS A PREVIOUS
PANELISTS NOTED ANY AGENDA ALSO
NOTED. MANY OF THESE PROPOSALS
ARE VERY TECHNICAL IN NATURE
SUCH AS AT TWELVE HUNDRED
CLEANUP OR CLARIFYING THE
FINANCIAL PENALTIES FOR FAILURE
TO COMPLY WITH DISTRICT
LEARNING STATUTES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON A NECESSARY
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THESE
PROPOSALS. THEY HAVE WITH ME
ELIZABETH YOUR SIGN DIRECTOR OF
CITIES WE'LL FISCAL SERVICES
DIVISION TO ANSWERING
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS REGARDED
REGARDING THESE PROPOSALS THANK
YOU. R. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BOMB I THINK. THERE'S A CHANCE
I MIGHT HAVE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT'LL BE CONCERNED AS WE MOVE
TOWARD THE MAY REVISED BUT
WE'RE SHORT ON TIME SO I'M A
NOT GOING TO ASK THEM TODAY I
WAS INTERESTED IN THE QUESTION
OF HOW THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR ADULTS IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS DIFFERS FROM PREVIOUS
PROPOSALS BUT WE'LL JUST ASK
THAT OUT OF HERE. IN THE WOMAN
US SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS NO OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK THE PANEL
APOLOGIZE FOR THE- VERY QUICKLY
WITH WHICH WE WENT THROUGH THAT
PARTICULAR ONE. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND THE IT'S ON ANY OF THE
SEVEN ITEMS OF THAT WE HEARD
TODAY THE REMINDER IS IT
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX OH NINE- I'M GOING TO
LIMIT. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS IN
TIME AND- THE DAY ANY TESTIMONY
TO ONE MINUTE TO ALL ON FORCED
TO QUORUM UNDER N. TWO WE HAVE
TO A HEARING ROOM SOMEONE ME
ASK IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
HEARING ROOM- THAT WISHES TO
ADDRESS THE- COMMITTEE. SAYING
NO ONE WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THAT WISHES TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. SEEING
NO ONE WE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE- SERVICE
MODERATOR WELCOME. TO THE
COMMITTEE AND IF YOU WOULD
PROFIT ANY INDIVIDUALS THAT
WISH TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE ME YOUR
PUBLIC. BY TELEPHONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS. THANK YOU AND
THAT IS A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE'LL GO TO THE FIRST QUESTION.
THOSE MINE THIRTY ONE. THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
AARON ASKING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS TO
RECRUIT RETAIN AND SUPPORT A
DIVERSE AMAKER PARA EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INCLUDING THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION EXPANSION OF
CRITICAL TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO
EXPAND THE GOLDEN STATE FUTURE
PROGRAMS AND DEDICATED FNDING
FOR EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
FEEDBACK OR CIRCLE TURNITIN.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND IN THE
PALESTINIAN COMMUNITY FOR
COMMUNITIES CALLED MATTER OF
THE HIGHEST NEED AREAS IN GREAT
DECISIONS FOR CONSIDER
GEOGRAPHIC AND REGIONAL
DIVERSITY APPLAUSE GRADE LEVELS
THERE. MENISCAL COORDINATORS
ABOUT BUILDING SCHOOL CAPACITY.
OF PARTNER. COORDINATORS ARE
INTO LOOK UP AT UNITY OKAY TO
BE A REQUIRE CUP. IN FRONT.
LASTLY LONG TERM IF. WHAT HE
NEED ONLY ORDER. MINUTE THANK
ONLY PLAN LAMENT ANY VALUE
PROGRESS IF YOU NEED LIKE PART
WITH YOU TO. ADDITIONALLY
DEDICATE FUNDING FOR TAX THIS
WITH ME TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE MANAGER RIGHT COMMENTS-
I UNDERSTAND SHE THANK THANK
VERY MUCH A MODERN NECK CALLER.
OUR NEXT. FROM LINE TWENTY. TWO
FOUR YOUR LINE OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN LINGER ON
THE OPPOSITE CHARTER SCHOOL AS-
WE SUBMITTED A BLANK- LETTER
BUT IN THE IN OF TIME- JUST
BECAUSE YOU TO DO SEVEN.
REGARDING DIED IN KIND OF BILL
ISSUES DIRECTLY THE CAN THAT
THE LACK OF DATA WILL PRESENT
FOR ALL ALL FOR SCHOOL. HOWEVER
THE DATA GAP SIGNIFICANT UNIQUE
IMPACT FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS BY
COMPLETELY UPENDING THE
STATUTORY STRUCTURE FOR HIGH.
STAKES RENEWAL DECISIONS- THIS
ISSUE WILL NEED TO BE
EXPLICITLY ADDRESSED TO ENSURE
STABILITY FOR STUDENT
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS WE WOULD
REQUEST THE ENGAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP TO EXPLORE ENACT
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE WITH THE COMMITTEE- IN
REGARD TO ISSUE SEVEN AND ADULT
CHARTERS- WE NOTE THAT THIS
ISSUE WAS PROPOSED LAST SPRING
AND REJECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS PROVIDED
SECOND CHANCE FOR INCARCERATED
STUDENTS MIGRANT WORKERS. AND
OTHERS WHO WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL
IN HIS TRADITIONAL SYSTEM AND
YET THEY REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
LIMITING ACCESS TO THESE
PROGRAMS WE WOULD FURTHER NOTE
THAT THE DRAFT LANGUAGE
CONTAINS SOME AMBIGUITY
REGARDING HOW DISTINCT SCHOOLS
WOULD BE IMPACTED. BY THE NEW
REQUIREMENT THAT WE'D LIKE TO-
FURTHER FOR THIS PROPOSAL WITH
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. THANK YOU LINE TO TWO TO
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HOW ARE IN WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND
I'M STICKING TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. FIFTY THREE OPPOSES HIS
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL TO
FURTHER RESTRICT PARTICIPATION
STUDENTS WHO ARE OVER AGE
NINETEEN CURRENT LAW REFLECTS A
LONGSTANDING CAREFULLY CRAFTED
COMPROMISE THAT COULD NOT BE
AND THAT. THE CONNECTED THE
LANGUAGE WOULD RESULT IN
THOUSANDS OF NONTRADITIONAL
AGED ADULT BLACK HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS FROM GRADUATING AND
BECOMING MORE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN SOCIETY AND THE
ECONOMY. MANY SAID STUDENTS ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS WELL SOME IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ARGUED THAT THE
STUDENTS SHOULD BE SERVED
THROUGH ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS ARE
SUBJECT TO LOW CAPS. AND WHOLLY
INADEQUATE FUNDING LEVELS.
ALTHOUGH IT THE POUND FOR. WE
BELIEVE SENATE HIGHER PRIORITY
FOR EARLY I SHOULD BE TO REACH
THE FUNDING. BY FROM YEAR'S
BUDGET PROVIDERS. MANY OF OUR
MEMBER SCHOOLS ARE NOW SERVING
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS FOR WHICH
THEY RECEIVED THEIR OUTSTANDING.
POTENTIAL BEGS THE
LEGISLATURE'S EARLY INFECTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARM NEXT COLUMN. BERMAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KERRY CAN ON BEHALF THE
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE A
COMPREHENSIVE CHILDREN SERVICE
AGENCY IN LOS ANGELES WORKING
TO TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN EXPOSED TO TRAUMA AND
THAT PERSON HE RESPONDED THANK
IN MINISTRATION PER AGAIN
MAKING COMMINGLED A PRIORITY
NONPROFITS LIKE CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE ARE KEY TO THE
SUCCESS OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
WHICH IS ROOTED IN PARTNERSHIPS
THAT LEVERAGE THE ESTABLISHED
AND TRUSTED NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCES.
HOWEVER CURRENTLY THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE FOR ELEAZAR ACCESS
THE STYLISH AND PROVEN
EXPERTISE OF NONPROFIT TO
PARTNER AND INTEGRATE THE
SOCIAL ACADEMIC SUPPORT WHICH
IS AT THE CORE OF THE COMMUTER
SCHOOL STRATEGY TO OUR TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROVIDING THE
INTEGRATED SUPPORT LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT THIS TIME WE
ARE ENGAGING COLLABORATIVE
LEADERSHIP DURING DISTANCE
LEARNING WHERE DRAFTING FAMILY
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC SUPPORT IN
COORDINATED. LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE POSSIBLE
THIS IS A COMMUTER SCHOOL WITH
AN INTENTIONAL NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIP LEVERAGING THE
NONPROFIT RESOURCES SO WE URGE
THE STATE TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR ELEAZAR PARTNER
WITH NONPROFITS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING GAUGE
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON THIS
IMPORTANT MISSION AT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU LINE SO.
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SERRA
WILLIS THE KEY PLUS ON BEHALF
OF OUR PARTICULARLY WE WANT TO
SPEAK ON ISSUES THREE FOUR AND
FIVE QUICKLY- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INVESTMENTS IN
ADDRESSING TEACHER SHORTAGES AS
WELL BUILDING THE PIPELINE. BUT
LIKE THE L. A- WE SUPPORT
PRIORITIZING AREAS BOTH OF
WHICH- DISTINCT TEACHER
SHORTAGES. WE ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THE OPPORTUNITY IN
THESE INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING
ISSUES IN OUR DEMOGRAPHIC MAKE
UP. AND THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
TEACHING FORCE WE SO WE
RECOMMEND. PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITIES WITH THE BIGGEST
GAPS. BETWEEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THEIR STUDENTS AND THOSE OF
THEIR TEACHERS. BUT ALSO OUR
SUPPORT OF MORE ROBUST
EVALUATION OF THE IMPACT OF
THESE INVESTMENTS. NOT ONLY
THAT YOU DRESS INTO GRANTS IN
THE PAST BY PROGRAM. BUT ALSO
SOLD SIX DIFFERENT PROGRAM- WE
ALSO THINK IN ADDITION TO
PRIORITIZE DIVERSITY GREETED
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON
BUILDING A TEACHING FORCE. THAT
CREATES CULTURALLY AFFIRMING
AND CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
SCHOOL- AND THIS CRISIS HAS
HIGHLIGHTED HOW IMPORTANT
INTRODUCTION IS A SUPPORT FOR
NEW TEACHERS. AND THERE'S%
SIGNIFICANT VARIATION- IN THE
STRUCTURE OF THE CAPACITY OF
THESE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE DISRUPTION
TO PRE SERVICE TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS. TO REALLY INVEST IN
DEVELOPING AND SUPPORTING
INDUCTION AND IN PROGRAMS WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE DESIGNATED
STAFFER DESIGNATED TIME. TO
SUPPORT OUR NEW TEACHERS. AND
THE NONPROFESSIONAL. YOU'VE
GONE. YOU'VE GONE A BIT OVER A
WANTED MAN IT WILL LOOK AT YOUR
COMMENT THANKS FOR CALLING A
MODERATOR. NIGHTINGALE HER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT LINES EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS WCF ON THE BORDERS GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
COMMENTS RELATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR DEMONSTRATING
BASIC SKILLS COMPETENCY BUT
BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENT IS
APPLICABLE TO TEACHERS AND
SUBSTITUTE CONVERGENCES PERMIT
HOLDERS SCHOOLS IN HIGH POVERTY
COMMUNITIES OFTEN DEBATE
CONTINUES AND HARD TO FILL
POSITIONS WITH LONG TERM
SUBSTITUTES FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
THE LANGUAGE PROPOSES THE
LETTER. GRADES FOR SPECIFIED
COURSEWORK. IN THE- FROM
ASSEMBLY SKILLS. SIMELANE WAS
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR IN THE
ASSEMBLY IS A POSSIBILITY HELD
IN THE SENATE. WE HAVE CONCERNS
OF THE LACK OF UNIFORMITY OF
LETTER GRADES ACROSS CAMPUSES
OF THE HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE COLLEGES THAT OFFER
COURSES IN THE A CATEGORY
SPECIFIED. ALSO NOTE THE DETAIL
COURSE AND GREATER EDUCATION
AND LABOR INTENSIVE. IN
CONTRAST THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ESTABLISH A PREREQUISITE HI TO
ACTUALLY OPINION ASSOCIATES
DEGREE OR BACCALAUREATE IN THE
SPECIFIED DISCIPLINE. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO REQUIRE SOME SET
REPORTING BACK UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF EXPANDING EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDING. PARTICULARLY ON THE
DISTRIBUTION OF KNOWLEDGE
TEACHERS AND LONG TERM
SUBSTITUTES IN SCHOOLS IN HIGH
POVERTY COMMUNITIES. ACCORDING
TO THE RECOMMENDED. YOU'VE GOT
A YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE THING. A
MINUTE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU. NEXT CALL. I MEAN MODERN
NEXT COURT. MAJOR LINE FORTY
FOUR THEY'RE ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT PROPOSED AND TO
SUPPORT EDUCATORS- CALIFORNIA
HAD A SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND AS
NOTED IN THE EXTENT THAT YOU TO
CALL THE NINETEEN MANY TEACHERS
ARE LEAVING THE PROFESSION ARE
RETIRING EARLY. SO WE STRONGLY
PRECOR INVESTING IN TEACHER
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT-
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT FROM PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND WANNA WORK WITH
YOU ON THE DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL. AND REGARDING THE
ADULT IN CHARTER SCHOOL
PROPOSAL VGA SUPPORT CLOSING
THE LOOPHOLE FOR ADULTS
GENERATED YES I FINDING WHICH
IS INTENDED FOR K. TWELVE
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. A MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU THIRTY NINE THREE
NINE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF BACA
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS PLEASE SUBMIT A LETTER
ON THE ADULT CHARTER SCHOOL CAP
ISSUE. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BONDS OF SPECIALIZED
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
ADULTS IN A DROPOUT RECOVERY
PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE.
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF PER SHARE
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
LINE FORTY TWO FOUR TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR THE
MARKETS WITH UNITED WAY IN
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE INVESTMENT COMMUNITY
SCHOOL WILL BE CRITICAL TO GET
COMMUNITY TO SUPPORT THE NEED
TO ENSURE THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE NOT. JUST MET AND
THE PANDEMIC UNFOLDS BUT IN
REAL TIME THE LONGEST RESPECT
WE'RE BUILDING RECOVERY IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS IT'LL BE
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO NOT FORGET
OUR SHELTER WORKERS AND CARERS
YOUR RECENTLY INTRODUCED AB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN AND THE GREEN
VISION HEALTHY START PROGRAM
THAT WOULD PROVIDE TARGETED
COMING FROM RESPONSE THAT CAN
WORK WITH YOU TO SCHOOLS IN
UNISON TO HELP OUR YOUNGEST
AFFORDABLE STUDENT. LEARNING
CHILD CARE CENTERS AND PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO QUALIFY FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL LIKE BRAND
ESTABLISHING THESE TYPES OF
INNOVATIVE COLLABORATIVE
COMMUNITIES HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC TO PROVIDE BLUEPRINT
OF HOW TO BEST INCENTIVIZING
TRADITION GRANT USED FORTY PST
CHEAT AND MEDIKAL INSURE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. WILL TO LIVE FORTY
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CHRIS
BOLLINGER WITH HIGHLAND
COMMUNITY CHARTERED TECHNICAL
SCHOOLS COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AGE CAPITA
SUMMARY WHICH YOU CAN FIND ON
PAGE TWENTY SEVEN TODAY'S
AGENDA. HIGHLANDS PROVIDES
STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA BURNING
WISH RECEIVED TECHNICAL JOB
TRAINING AND TAKE CITIZENSHIP
CLASSES HIGHLANDS INTERPRET
HONORABLY LOW INCOME IMMIGRANTS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
EX OFFENDERS WHY WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK. THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US ON
THEIR PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE. WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO AND
YOU WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE AND WE DO HAVE A
FEW MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR
FOUR FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO EVERYONE MY. I RIGHT YOU
NEED TO MUTE EITHER YOUR
COMPUTER OR OTHER DEVICE BEHIND
YOU BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
FEEDBACK SO IT'S JUST YOU ON
YOUR PHONE. I'M SORRY AW HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME WOULD BE GIVEN
TO YOU AND I FIFTY SIX YEARS
OLD I THOUGHT THEY'D BE.
OUTSIDE PROGRAM MORE THAN
ANOTHER THE SCHOOL PROGRAM.
THAT I HAVE ATTENDED IN THE
PAST. I WANT TO THANK THE IT
THINK THIS WOULD HAVE CHáVEZ
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND STAFF
WILL PROVIDING ME WITH THE
TOOLS THAT I NEED TO WITH MY
LOCATION OF COURSE. I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THIS PROGRAM TO
EVERYONE THAT LED ME CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT KNOWING
THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF. SB
FIFTY FOUR CHARLIE PRICE WHO
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION
WHILE HAVING TO WORK IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE FOR A FAMILY. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODEL NEXT
QUOTE. LINE THIRTY USERS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
AND FLOOR I'M FORTY YEAR OLD I
GREAT FROM BACHELORS CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE STARTUP
THINKING THE NINETY. GROWING UP
IN AN AFTER TO THE COULD IN THE
LIFE OF MY LIKE ME TELL BECAUSE
CHRISTIAN OR HAS GRADUATE ALSO
THE SECOND AND TEACHERS PUSHED
SUPPORT TO THE- TO BOTH BE ON
THE HIGH SCHOOL. SOMETHING I
DID NOT FROM HER ADULT SCHOOL
I'M CURRENTLY MY LAST SO FOR OF
THE- IN THE HONOR ROLL GRADE
UNIT- BE GREAT MAY WITH A
DOUBLE THE IN ENGLISH AND- MY
POETRY THEM CALL BY THE- I HAVE
BEEN THAT THE TO THE CALL
MEMBERS. COCKPIT RICH QUALITY
ONE WITH A NUMBER TO JOIN THE
IT LOOK CONSCIOUSLY. I'M
CURRENTLY AWAY THERE WAS FROM
YOU SEE ARE YOU FEELING IS AND-
CHEN. THOSE NOTICES YOU'RE
ABOUT TO RECEIVE MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE THIRTY FIVE THREE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN- IN SENATOR MAN THIS
IS JEFF ROSS. CALLING ON BEHALF
OF B. EXPLORE IT LOOKS FORWARD
TAURAN'S K. TWELVE SCIENCE
LEADER NETWORK WE WOULD URGE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
RESTORATION OF THE THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THERE WAS
REDUCED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S
ITEMS IN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WE SUPPORT THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR EXPANSION OF THE MTAS
US- PROGRAM BY AND WE I
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MAN FOR HIS COMMENTS OF
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
ELEVEN ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KLEIN ELEVEN ARE YOU ON
MUTE. PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
COMMENT. WILL MOVE ON LINE TEN
ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO COLOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE MUTE YOUR COMPUTER. IF
YOU CALL THIS QUESTION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR
ASSISTING US TODAY THROUGH
THIS. ARE REALLY APPRECIATED.
BY THAT BRINGS US TO OUR CLOSE
SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE ANY-
FINAL COMMENTS. THEN LET ME
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY OR DIDN'T HAVE
THE FULL TIME TO COMPLETE YOUR
ORAL TESTIMONY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. OF THOSE
COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL RECORD AND
AGAIN THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANKED EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WITH
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IS ADJOURNED.